GOOD AFTERNOON
THE ASSEMBLY TRANSPORTATION
COMMITTEE IS CALLED TO ORDER.
WE ARE CONTINUING TO PRACTICE
PHYSICAL DISTANCING IN THE
HEARING ROOM AND THROUGHOUT THE
CAPITAL SO WE ARE ONLY ABLE TO
HAVE A LIMITED NUMBER OF PEOPLE
WALK TO PARTICIPATE IN THE
HEARING IN PERSON. YOU CAN
TESTIFY IN PERSON IN THE
HEARING ROOM AT THE REMOTE
TESTIMONY STATION ON THE
CAPITOL GROUNDS OR USING OUR
TELEPHONE SERVICE. MASKS ARE
REQUIRED FOR ALL INDIVIDUALS IN
THE HEARING ROOM AT THE REMOTE
TESTIMONY STATION ON THE
CAPITOL GROUNDS THE NUMBER TO
CALL IS. EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN SIX
NINE TWO EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN.
AND THE ACCESS CODE IS. TWENTY
FOUR TO SIX TO THIRTY SEVEN
THAT'S 877-692-8959 ACCESS CODE
TWENTY FOUR SIX SORRY. TWENTY
FOUR TO SIX TO THIRTY SEVEN.
FOR EACH BILL BEING DISCUSSED
TODAY THERE WILL BE THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR TWO WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION TO
PROVIDE TWO MINUTES EACH OF
COMMENTARY. FOR ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES CALLING INTO THE
PHONE LINE YOU WILL BE PLACED
IN A QUEUE UNTIL YOUR
OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT. PLEASE MUTE YOUR
DEVICES TO REDUCE SOUND
DISTORTIONS. SUPPORTED
OPPOSITION WE BLENDED ON THE
PHONE LINE PLEASE BE BRIEF AND
LIMIT YOUR COMMENTS TO YOUR
NAME ORGANIZATION AND POSITION
WE WILL STRICTLY ENFORCE THIS
IF YOU GIVE ANY TESTIMONY
BEYOND NAME ORGANIZATION A
POSITION. YOU WILL BE CUT OFF
BY THE OPERATOR. IF YOU'RE
HAVING ANY PROBLEMS WITH A
MODERATED PHONE SERVICE YOU CAN
CALL THE COMMITTEE AT
916-319-2090 THREE AND WILL TRY
TO HELP. ENCOURAGE THE PUBLIC
TO PROVIDE WRITTEN TESTIMONY
THROUGH POSITION LET THE
POSITION LETTER PORTAL IN THE
COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE. FINALLY
THE ASSEMBLY HAS EXPERIENCED A
NUMBER OF DISRUPTIONS TO
COMMITTEE AND FOR PROCEEDINGS
IN THE LAST FEW YEARS. ANY
CONDUCT THAT DISRUPTS DISTURBS
OR OTHERWISE IMPEDE THE ORDERLY
CONDUCT OF THE HEARING AND THE
PUBLIC'S RIGHT TO SPEAK WILL BE
PROHIBITED. SEPT CONDUCT MAY
INCLUDE REMOVING A MASK
REFUSING TO PUT IT BACK ON.
TALKING OR MAKING LOUD NOISES
FROM THE AUDIENCE UTTERING LOUD
THREATENING OR ABUSIVE LANGUAGE
SPEAKING LONGER THAN THE TIME
ALLOTTED. EXTENDED DISCUSSION
OF MATTERS NOT RELATED TO THE
SUBJECT OF THE HEARING OF THE
BILL AND OTHER DESTRUCTIVE ACTS.
TO ADDRESS ANY DISRUPTIVE
CONDUCT I WILL TAKE THE
FOLLOWING STEPS. IF IT
INDIVIDUAL DISRUPTS OUR HEARING
PROCESS I WILL DIRECT THEM TO
STOP AND WARNED THEM THAT
CONTINUED DISRUPTIONS MAY
RESULT IN REMOVAL FROM THE
CAPITOL BUILDING. I WILL ALSO
DOCUMENT ON THE RECORD THE
INDIVIDUAL INVOLVED IN THE
NATURE OF THE CONDUCT I MAY
TEMPORARILY RECESSED THE
HEARING. IF THE CONDUCT DOES
NOT STOP I WILL REQUEST THE
ASSISTANCE OF THE SERGEANTS AND
EXPORTING THE INDIVIDUAL FROM
THE CAPITOL BUILDING. THANK YOU
ALL FOR YOUR COOPERATION. WITH
THAT WE'RE GOING TO BEGIN OUR
HEARING- SECRETARY DO WANNA
CALL ROLLER WAIT UNTIL WE HAVE
A QUORUM. INTEL HAD A CALL ROLE
NOW OKAY. FRIEDMAN HERE
FRIEDMAN HERE FONG. BERMAN.
CUNNINGHAM DALY. DAVIES STATUS
HERE GIPSON. KALRA LEE READ
HERE MEDINA IN THIS AREA. WHEN
O'DONNELL. WARD WICKS. HIS WILL
BE BEGINNING AS A SUB COMMITTEE
UNTIL WE ESTABLISH A QUORUM WE
DO HAVE ONE CORRECTION TO MAKE
FROM THE PRINTER MATERIALS ACR
SEVENTY NINE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
NAZARIAN WAS NOTICED IN THE
DAILY FILE TO BE HEARD TODAY
BUT WE'RE GOING TO BE TAKING
THAT UP INSTEAD ON JULY FIFTH.
WE HAVE THE FOLLOWING MEASURES
ON CONSENT SB TWO FOURTEEN. SB
SIX FORTY. SB EIGHT FOURTEEN.
SB SIX SEVENTY ONE. S. C. R.
TWENTY SEVEN. SB THREE NINETY
NINE S. C. R. TWENTY EIGHT. AND
A C. R. EIGHTY EIGHT O'DONNELL.
WE WILL WAIT TO HAVE A MOTION
ON THE CONSENT FILE UNTIL WE
HAVE A QUORUM. AND WE HAVE SIX
BILLS LEFT TO DISCUSS TODAY I
DON'T SEE ANY AUTHOR SO WHOEVER
GETS YOUR FIRST WE'LL BE ABLE
TO BE HEARD IMMEDIATELY. THOSE
SIX BILLS ARE SB SIXTY SIX BY
ALLEN SB FIVE FORTY EIGHT
EGGMAN SB TWO TWO SEVEN JONES
SB TWO. SORRY SB THREE SEVENTY
TWO LEYVA SB FIVE HUNDRED MEN
SB THREE THIRTY NINE WIENER. I
INVITE ANY AUTHOR TO OPEN ON
ANY BILL ON OUR AGENDA.
HOW
MANY DO WE NEED PERFORMED. OKAY.
YEAH LOOK ALIVE. YEAH SURE WE
DON'T GET OFFICE WE ALWAYS HAVE
NEXT MONDAY. AND WE HAD TWO
MORE MEMBERS WE CAN START
VOTING ON THINGS.
YEAH OKAY.
YEAH.
OKAY. ALL.
THEY'RE STILL
IN SESSION.
GOOD OKAY. WE HAVE
SOME WE HAVE SOME ON THEIR WAY.
WE WILL BE A ONE. HELLO.
GREAT
WELCOME SENATOR ALAN. HI THERE.
YOU MAY PRESENT WHENEVER YOU
ARE READY. SENDING IN THE
ASSEMBLY PARTS. SO HERE WE ARE
OKAY SO THANK YOU SO MUCH
MEMBERS FOR- HEARING AS THE SB
SIXTY SIX THIS IS A BILL THAT
WAS PASSED ON A UNANIMOUS
BIPARTISAN VOTE OVER ON THE
SENATE SIDE THAT- THAT
BASICALLY ESTABLISHES AN
ADVISORY COMMITTEE KNOWN AS THE
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL IN THE
FUTURE OF TRANSPORTATION
PARTICULAR LOOKING AT THE ISSUE
OF AUTONOMOUS VEHICLES MEMBERS
ARE WE KNOW THAT AUTONOMOUS
VEHICLES ARE- IN OUR FUTURE
WHETHER WE LIKE IT OR NOT. AND
THE QUESTION IS ARE WE GOING TO
ADOPT THIS TECHNOLOGY IN A WAY
THAT IS THOUGHTFUL THAT IS
MINDFUL THAT TIME IS ACTUALLY
PREPARES OUR SOCIETY OR IS IT
JUST KIND OF SORT OF HAPPENED
IN A HAPHAZARD WAY IF YOU THINK
ABOUT SOME OF THE MAJOR
TECHNOLOGICAL CHANGES THAT
HAPPEN IN THE PAST INCLUDING
THE ADVENT OF THE AUTOMOBILE IN
THE FIRST PLACE IF WE ACTUALLY
SPENT SOME TIME TO BE A LITTLE
THOUGHTFUL ABOUT THE ROLL OUT
OF THAT TECHNOLOGY. ADD IN THE
IMPACT IT WOULD HAVE AND
EVERYTHING FROM URBAN PLANNING
TO SAFETY TO PUBLIC- TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT I TO COMMUTE
PATTERNS AND THE DESIGN OF
CITIES- WE MIGHT OF- WE MIGHT
OF- CHRIS AND BENEFITS AND SO
THIS IS ALL ABOUT UNDERSTANDING
OF THIS TECHNOLOGY IS THERE
IT'S VERY LIKELY TO IMPACT THE
WAY THAT WE GET AROUND AS A
SOCIETY. AND IT'S ABOUT GETTING
TOGETHER SOME SMART THOUGHTFUL
PEOPLE EARLY. TO START THAT
PLANNING PROCESS. OKAY THANK
YOU SO MUCH OF IT DO YOU HAVE
ANY WITNESSES WITH YOU HERE
TODAY ARE ON THE LINE TO
TESTIFY. I'M NOT SURE OKAY
THAT'S OKAY SORRY THAT'S QUITE
ALRIGHT- SO I'M GOING TO NOW
ASK IF THERE'S ANYBODY IN THE
CHAMBERS WHO WISHES TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. WE HAVE
NINE IF THERE IS ANYONE. IN THE
IN THE CHAIN IT ANYBODY IN THE
TWO WEEKS ALL THE OVERFLOW ROOM
OR THE- REMOTE TESTIMONY. OKAY
DO WE HAVE ANYONE IN THE REMOTE
TESTIMONY LOCATION TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. NO DO WE
HAVE ANYBODY IN THE CHAMBERS TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION ON THE BILL.
NOPE ANYONE IN THE REMOTE.
TESTIMONY ROOM. OKAY NOW WE'RE
GOING TO GO TO THE PHONE LINES
AN OPERATOR IF THERE ARE ANY OF
THE- PRIMARY WITNESSES TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT. YOU MAY BRING THEM
IN FIRST OTHERWISE THIS WILL BE
THE GENERAL TESTIMONY EITHER IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION OF THE
BILL. IF YOU CAN OPEN THE PHONE
LINES PLEASE. CURABITUR LINES
OPEN. IT LOOKS LIKE WE HAVE A
LITTLE BIT AND JACQUELINE. OKAY.
I KNOW THAT IRVINE I CAN I CAN
JUMP IN OKAY YES YOU ARE
REGISTERED AS A WITNESS IN
SUPPORT SO YOU WILL HAVE TWO
MINUTES TO SPEAK PLEASE YEAH.
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIRWOMAN FRIEDMAN AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
ELIZABETH IRVINE I'M A SENIOR
TRANSPORTATION ANALYST. WITH
THE UNION OF CONCERNED
SCIENTISTS. AT UCS IS THE
NATION'S LEADING SCIENCE BASED
NONPROFIT PUTTING RIGOROUS
INDEPENDENT SCIENCE TO WORK TO
SOLVE OUR PLANET'S MOST
PRESSING PROBLEMS. ON BEHALF OF
UCF IS FORTY FOUR THOUSAND PLUS
SUPPORTERS IN CALIFORNIA. I AM
PLEASED TO SPEAK TODAY IN
SUPPORT OF SB SIXTY SIX. WHICH
ESTABLISHES AN ADVISORY
COMMITTEE ON AUTONOMOUS VEHICLE
TECHNOLOGY. AS AS SENATOR ALLEN
POINTED OUT. AB TECHNOLOGY HAS
THE POTENTIAL TO SIGNIFICANTLY
ALTER OUR TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM
WITH FAR REACHING IMPLICATIONS
FOR CARBON EMISSIONS AIR
POLLUTION. SAFETY EQUITABLE
MOBILITY AND THE STATE'S
ECONOMY. THIS BILL WILL SET UP
A PROCESS AND A FORUM DEVOTED
TO DIRECTING THE DEVELOPMENT
AND DEPLOYMENT OF AUTOMATED
TECHNOLOGY. TO MAXIMIZE
POTENTIAL BENEFITS AND MINIMIZE
POTENTIAL HEART. CRUCIALLY THIS
BILL ALSO PROVIDES FOR
REPRESENTATION OF A DIVERSE
RANGE OF STAKEHOLDERS
EXPERTISE. AND ALSO REQUIRES
THE COUNCIL TO DIRECT TO
CONSIDER PUBLIC COMMENTS. I
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SPEAK WITH YOU TODAY I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOU TO VOTE IN
FAVOR OF SB SIXTY SIX THANK YOU
AND WE ALSO JACQUELINE BETH
WITH. TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OPERATOR. YES I AM ON. CAN YOU
HEAR ME YES. HI YES THIS IS
JACKIE OKAY THANK YOU- GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF
THE TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE-
MY NAME IS JACQUELINE BACK WHEN
I AM A MANAGER OF GOVERNMENT
RELATIONS- AT THE ASSOCIATION
FOR UNMANNED VEHICLE SYSTEMS
INTERNATIONAL WE ARE THE
WORLD'S LARGEST NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATION DEDICATED TO THE
ADVANCEMENT OF UNMANNED SYSTEMS
AND ROBOTICS THAT WE REPRESENT
OPERATIONS AND PROFESSIONALS
FROM MORE THAN SIXTY COUNTRIES
INVOLVED IN INDUSTRY GOVERNMENT
AND ACADEMIA. THE COUNCIL
ESTABLISHED BY SB SIXTY SIX
WOULD PROVIDE THE SPACE
NECESSARY TO WORK THROUGH THE
CRITICAL AND THORNY QUESTIONS
AROUND THE CONTINUED
DEVELOPMENT AND DEPLOYMENT OF
AUTONOMOUS VEHICLE TECHNOLOGY
PARTICULARLY THE ATTENTION NEED
TO MEMBERSHIP OF THE COUNCIL IS
INDICATIVE OF THE WHOLE
PLANNING AROUND THE DIVERSITY
OF VOICES THAT NEED TO BE HEARD
IN THE CONTEXT OF THE
TECHNOLOGY. THERE ARE VARIOUS
APPLICATIONS OF AUTOMATED
VEHICLE TECHNOLOGY THAT WILL
BRING THE MOST BENEFIT TO
CALIFORNIANS SUCH AS BLOCK NOT
THE LIVERY FREIGHT AND
LOGISTICS AND TRANSIT TO BE
SURE THERE ARE VARIOUS
CHALLENGES TO WORK THROUGH ON
THE WAY CONTRAST APPOINTMENT
BUT THE COUNCIL REPRESENTS
NINETY A VENUE THROUGH WHICH TO
ADDRESS THOSE QUESTIONS LIKE
WHAT WILL EIGHTY JOB LOOK LIKE
HOUSING THE TECHNOLOGY BEING
SURE IT HAPPENED CLIMATE
BENEFIT THE MAXIMIZED AND
WORKING EIGHTEEN COMPLEMENT
PUBLIC SAFETY. NEEDS ANOTHER
QUESTION SHOUL BE THOROUGHLY
DISCUSSED AND DEBATED AMONG ALL
STAKEHOLDERS AND HER COUNSEL IS
GONNA CONVERSATIONS SHOULD TAKE
QUITE IF YOU THINK THE PAST
CALIFORNIA WILL JOIN OTHER
STATES WITH SIMILAR EIGHTY
COUNCIL AN ADS I ON BEHALF OF
INDUSTRY HOW TO SUPPORT THAT
EFFORT THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY AND I
RESPECTFULLY URGE YOUR I'M.
BUILT ON SB SIXTY. THE YOU VERY
MUCH WE HAVE NO. ON FILE TO
SPEAK TO SO I IF YOU CAN OPEN
UP THE LINES ANY OTHER. WHO
WISH TO. SPEAK EITHER IN-
SUPPORT OR IN OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL. THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO
MAKE A COMMENT JOHN S. B. SIXTY
SIX PLEASE PRESS ONE BENZIE ROW
AT THIS TIME. AND WE HAVE ABOUT
TWO COMMENTS THANK YOU IT'LL
JUST BE ONE MOMENT FOR THE
FIRST COMMENTS. BY NINETY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. RIGHT NINE SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE MORE
MOMENT FOR FIRST COMMENTS. NO
EFFECT ON. WHICH I WON SEVENTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES SIR
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE TIM CHANG WITH THE
ARTICLE THE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL AND
URGING AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU I
HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENTS THANK
YOU AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU NOW
FROM THE BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
ACTUALLY BEFORE WE GO TO THE
COMMITTEE WHY DON'T WE
ESTABLISH A QUORUM INTEGRAL.
OKAY FONG. BERMAN. BERMAN I
CUNNINGHAM. CUNNINGHAM NOPE-
GIPSON GIPSON HERE KALRA KALRA
HERE MEDINA MEDINA HERE
NAZARIAN. WHEN O'DONNELL.
O'DONNELL HERE BUT OVER HERE.
WICKS WE HAVE A QUORUM. THANK
YOU. WE. OKAY LET ME SEE IF ANY
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE HAVE
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FOR
THE AUTHOR. HEY WE HAVE A
MOTION AND I HEARD OF SECONDS
FROM SOMEWHERE. MOTION FOR
MISTER GIBSON. WHO IS THE
SECOND. MISTER O'DONNELL OKAY
THANK YOU- MR ALLEN I
APPRECIATE YOU BRINGING THIS
BILL FORWARD SO THAT WE CAN
PREPARE FOR OUR THOMAS VEHICLE
FUTURE ABOUT 94% OF OUR ALMOST
FORTY THOUSAND AUTO ACCIDENTS A
YEAR ARE CAUSED BY HUMAN ERROR
AND I PERSONALLY BELIEVE THAT
MY- FIFTEEN DOLLAR BLACK AND
DECKER TOASTER OVEN COULD
PROBABLY DRIVE BETTER THAN A
LOT OF. SO I'M LOOKING FORWARD
TO SEEING THIS FUTURE ABOUT OF
COURSE IS A LOT OF ISSUES WE
HAVE TO GRAPPLE WITH AND HAVING
THIS KIND OF COUNCIL WILL GIVE
US A MORE HOLISTIC LOOK AT ALL
OF THE IMPACTS THAT THESE
VEHICLES WILL HAVE SO I THINK
YOU FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD
AND I AM SUPPORTIVE OF THE
BILL. I WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE.
YOUR COMMENTS. THAT'S REALLY.
YOU THIS THE SAFETY ISSUES
ENORMOUS ONE. THAT THERE'S A
LOT OF OTHER ISSUES AS WELL. AS
A THIS IS. A WAY FOR US TO
THOUGHTFULLY APPROACH THIS.
THIS FUTURE. SO I APPRECIATE
YOUR- CONSIDERATION THIS BILL
AND RESPECT FOR US FOR A VOTE.
THANK YOU WITH THAT CAN WE HAVE
A ROLL CALL PLEASE. THE MOTION
IS TO PASS TO COMMUNICATIONS
AND CONVEYANCE FRIEDMAN. HI
FRIEDMAN I FALL. ANOTHER NOT
FOR NOT VOTING BERMAN BERMAN HI
CUTTING HIM. DALY DALY AYE
DAVIES. DAVIES HI SIR DAVIES I
GIPSON GIPSON I KALRA. KALRA I
LEE THREE I MEDINA MEDINA AYE
NAZARIAN. WHEN O'DONNELL. SO
DONALD I WARD. WICKS. KERN VOTE
IS NINE ZERO THANK YOU MEMBERS
THANK YOU THANK YOU SENATOR
EGGMAN WELCOME. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- MANAGER MEMBERS I AM HERE
TODAY TO PRESENT SB. FIVE FORTY
EIGHT SO MY COLLEAGUES MAY FIND
IS SIMILAR THIS IS A FOLLOW UP
TO A BILL I AUTHORED A FEW
YEARS AGO THE AUTHORIZED THE
TRI VALLEY SAN JOAQUIN REGIONAL
RAIL AUTHORITY AND ASKED TO
TASK AND IDENTIFYING A SOMEONE
TO DELIVER THIS PROJECT THIS
WILL CONNECT. THE SAN JOAQUIN
COUNTY UP OVER THE HILL INTO
THE BAY AREA AND CONNECT WITH
BART- THIS IS THAT NOW UNDER
WAY AND NOW THIS BILL DOES A
COUPLE CLARIFICATIONS FOR THE
IMPLEMENTATION THIS BILL
CLARIFIES THAT THE STATUE
ENABLES THE AUTHORITY TO
OPERATE THE TRAIN. THIS STATUE
AS SAYS THE BILL TO LEAD TO
LANGUAGE THAT PREVIOUSLY SAID
THAT THE CONSTRUCTION POINT THE
CONNECTION POINT HAD TO OCCUR
IN THE TRI VALLEY AREA AFTER
STUDIES WE NOW THINK IT SHOULD
BE CONNECTED IN THE SAN JOAQUIN
COUNTY AREA. AND LASTLY THE
BILL ESTABLISHES THE AUTHORITY
AS A REAL TRANSIT DISTRICT FOR
PURPOSES OF EXEMPTING THE
PROJECT FROM THE LOCAL BUILDING
AND ZONING ORDINANCE THIS IS A
PROJECT OF TREMENDOUS
IMPORTANCE. IN THE SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY BAY AREA REGIONAL CUT
ONE UP OVER THAT FIVE EIGHTY IF
ANYONE TAKES THAT TRIP THEY'LL
KNOW HOW IMPORTANT IT IS FOR
REAL TO MOVE SOME OF THOSE
FOLKS MORE EFFICIENTLY THIS IS
A PROJECT THAT IS ALREADY NOW-
UNDERWEIGHT WE NEED TO HAVE THE
FINISH I HAVE. FUNDING IT- BUT
IT WILL IN INCREDIBLY INCREASE
AT THE QUALITY OF LIFE FOR MY
CONSTITUENTS AND THOSE OVER THE
HILL I WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR I. BUT WITH ME TODAY I
HAVE MICHAEL TREAT- TO TESTIFY
AS. WELL AS- THE PERSON. WHICH
WOULD BE TO THE PERSON WOULD BE
TONY MACAULAY REPRESENTING
DELIVER MORE AT AT AMADOR
VALLEY TRANSIT AUTHORITY. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH SAYS MR TREE IN
THE ROOM. I AM CAN YOU HEAR ME
YES SO YOU. YOU MAY GO ARE YOU
ON THE PHONE LINE RATE YOU MAY
PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE READY TWO
MINUTES PLEASE. THANK YOU WELL
GOOD AFTERNOON THAT YOU'RE
FRIEDMAN AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS
I MICHAEL TREE AND I'M THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR THE TRI
VALLEY. SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY
REGIONAL RAIL AUTHORITY AND I'M
HERE IN SUPPORT OF SB FIVE
FORTY EIGHT- AS MENTIONED DAY
AB SEVEN FIFTY EIGHT AUTHORED
BY THEN ASSEMBLY MEMBER EGGMAN.
CREATED THE RAIL AUTHORITY FOR
THE PURPOSE OF PLANNING AND
DELIVERING AT TRANSPORTATION.
NORTHERN SAN JOAQUIN COUNTY
TRAVELING TO THE BAY AREA. ON
WHAT'S OFTEN REFERRED TO AS A
DIFFICULT MEGA COMMUTE. SINCE
IT'S AN INSTANCE CREATION BY
THE STATE AT THE END OF TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN THE RAIL
AUTHORITY HAS BEEN REALLY BUSY
THE FIFTEEN MEMBER AGENCY HAS
COMPLETED THE STATE MANDATED
FEASIBILITY REPORT WHICH
IDENTIFIED THE VALLEY LINK RAIL
PROJECT AS THE PREFERRED
PROJECT. AND IT'S ALSO
COMPLETED THE ENVIRONMENTAL
WORK FOR THE PROJECT IN 15%
DESIGN AND MOST RECENTLY THE
RAIL AUTHORITY DESIGNATED THE
SAN JOAQUIN REGIONAL RAIL
COMMISSION AS THE PRESUMED
OPERATOR ABOUT A LINK. SO THE
PROJECT MOVING ALONG
EFFICIENTLY AND QUICKLY MAINLY
DUE TO THE ENTIRE PROJECT BEING
AND IN CURRENTLY EXISTING
TRANSPORTATION RIGHTS OF WAY.
VALLEY LINKS PROJECTED TO CARRY
THIRTY THREE THOUSAND RIDE
TODAY- TODAY IT NEARLY EIGHT
HUNDRED MILLION HAS BEEN
IDENTIFIED FOR THE PROJECT
WHICH IS ABOUT A THIRD OF THE
FUNDING NEEDED FOR COMPLETION
OF THE PROJECT. SO SB. FIVE
FORTY EIGHT- PROVIDES IMPORTANT
TOOLS AND CLARIFICATIONS THAT
ARE NEEDED FOR THE RAIL
AUTHORITY TO DELIVER THE VALLEY
LINK PROJECT IN WITH THAT SAID
ALL CLOSE MY COMMENTS AND ASK
YOUR SUPPORT OF SB FIVE FORTY
EIGHT THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND THAT IS MISTER
MACAULAY IN THE ROOM. OR ON THE
PHONE LINES YES. OKAY I'M ON
THE PHONE. YOU MAY BE. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR FRIEDMAN AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
TONY MACAULAY AND I'M
REPRESENTING THE LIVERMORE
AMADOR VALLEY TRANSIT AUTHORITY
THIS AFTERNOON. THE TRANSIT
AUTHORITY PROVIDES BUS SERVICE
IN THE BAY AREA'S TRI VALLEY.
AND IS ONE OF MANY MEMBER
AGENCIES WORKING TOGETHER TO
DELIVER THE BALLOT LINK
PROJECT. AT THE BOARD LEVEL OUR
AGENCY PROVIDES A POLICY MAKER
TO SERVE ON THE VALLEY LIKE
BOARD. AND AT THE EXECUTIVE
LEVEL OUR AGENCIES EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR SERVES ON THE BALLOT
LINK EXECUTIVE COMMITTEE. WHICH
HASDONE A GREAT JOB FOR A
PROVIDING CLOSE GUIDANCE. ON
THE DEVELOPMENT OF THE PROJECT.
OUR STAFF BEEN WORKING VERY
CLOSELY WITH VALLEY LINK STAFF
BARRED STAFF AND THE STAFF OF
THE SAN JOAQUIN REGIONAL RAIL
COMMISSION. WHICH OPERATES THE
A STRAIN. TO PLAN FOR
COMPLEMENTARY AND INTEGRATED
SERVICE TO ASSESS. THE NEARLY
ONE HUNDRED THOUSAND DAIRY
WORKERS TRAVELLING DAILY FROM
THE NORTHERN SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY
TO THE BAY AREA. IT IS OF NOTE
AND AN EXAMPLE OF THE CLOSE
WORKING RELATIONSHIPS BETWEEN
THE TRANSIT AGENCIES. THAT THE
SAN JOAQUIN REGIONAL RAIL
COMMISSION WAS NAMED TO BE
PRESENT OPERATOR FOR VALLEY
LINK AND BOTH BOARDS
UNANIMOUSLY APPROVED INITIAL
AND WILL USE FOR THIS PURPOSE.
WE RECOGNIZE THE IMPORTANCE OF
CLARIFYING THAT THE VALLEY LINK
BOARD HAS THE AUTHORITY TO
OPERATE DEVELOPING TRAIN SYSTEM
WHICH GIVES THEM THE ABILITY TO
DESIGNATE AN OPERATOR. THANK
YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK. THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE
DO HAVE ONE WITNESS IN
OPPOSITION LISTED DAVID SEAN
BYRNE IF MISTER SHAWN BROWN IS
IN THE ROOM. OR ON THE PHONE
LINE I'M ON THE PHONE OKAY YOU
HAVE TWO MINUTES. THANK YOU I'M
DAVID HOCHBERG PRESIDENT OF THE
TRAIN RIDERS ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA. THIS BILL WAS
SPONSORED BY AN AGENCY THAT THE
LEGISLATURE ORDER. WILL THEY
COST EFFECTIVE CONNECTION
BETWEEN ACE AND BART IT CAME UP
WITH THE GRANDIOSE PLANS THAT
GOES FAR BEYOND WHAT WAS ASKED
OF IT. AND THERE PROJECT WOULD
COST MORE THAN A BART EXTENSION
THIS BILL SEEKS YOUR
RETROACTIVE APPROVAL FOR A
GREATLY EXPANDED MISSION.
PLEASE DO NOT ENDORSE THEIR
MISSION CREEP. THIS BILL IS
ALSO AN ATTEMPT TO SECURE
BUREAUCRATIC IMMORTALITY.
BECAUSE THEY BE SEVEN FIFTY
EIGHT DID NOT GIVE THE
AUTHORITY THE POWER TO OPERATE
THE LEGISLATURE CLEARLY
INTENDED FOR THIS AGENCY TO
SUNSET AFTER IT DELIVERED ITS
PROJECT SIMILAR TO THE FORT
HILL CONSTRUCTION AUTHORITY IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA. THE VERY
LAST THING THE BAY AREA NEEDS
IS YET ANOTHER TRANSIT
OPERATING AGENCY. AS RAIL
ADVOCATES OUR ORGANIZATION HAS
WORKED FOR DECADES ON FASTER
RAIL TRANSPORTATION IN THE
ALTAMONTE QUARTER IN OUR EXPERT
OPINION THIS PROJECT IS A MULTI
BILLION DOLLAR WASTE OF MONEY.
IT IS INTENDED TO BRING PEOPLE
BY TRAIN TO ANOTHER TRAIN
INSTEAD OF TAKING THEM DIECTLY
WHERE THEY ACTUALLY WANT TO GO
WHICH IS SILICON VALLEY THAT'S
WHERE THE JOBS ARE. THOSE
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS COULD DO SO
MUCH MORE TO MOVE PEOPLE
BETWEEN THE VALLEY AND THE BAY
AREA IF THEY WERE SPENT ON A
SENSIBLE PROJECT TO SPEED UP A-
THE TRAIN RIDERS ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA RESPECTFULLY URGES A
NO VOTE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NOW IS THERE ANYONE IN THE ROOM
RUSHING TO VOICE THEIR SUPPORT
FOR THE BILL. PLEASE GO TO THE
MICROPHONE. GOOD ACTORS ARE
FRIEDMAN. MY NAME IS DR ARMAND
VALERIO I'M A PRIVATE CITIZEN
AND RESIDE IN STOCKTON
CALIFORNIA. AND I AM SUPPORT OF
SB FIVE FORTY EIGHT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANYONE ELSE.
IS THERE ANYONE IN THE CHAMBERS
WISHING TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
TO THE BILL. YOUR NOW OPEN THE
PHONE LINES IT WOULD DEPEND ON
THE FENCE PROJECT OKAY. THANK
YOU OPERATOR IF YOU CAN OPEN
THE PHONE LINES FOR THE BLENDED
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION- SB. FIVE FORTY
EIGHT. THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO
COMMENT ON SB FIVE FOUR EIGHT
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. I HAVE ABOUT SIX
COMMENTS THANK YOU WILL GO TO
ONE SEVENTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS MICHAEL PIMENTEL
HERE ON BEHALF OF THE COUNTY
SAN JOAQUIN IN SUPPORT- DRIVE
OUT. THANK YOU BYE EIGHTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS ON THE
DOCKS ON RITA'S ON BEHALF OF
THE TRI VALLEY CITIES OF DUBLIN
LIVERMORE PLEASANTON SAN RAMON
AND THE TOWN OF DANVILLE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE BILL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU I NINETY
ONE SHE'S GOING HAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE HOUSE THE CITY
OF STOCKTON IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL. THANK YOU I'M THIRTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE THREE
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME'S
JENNIFER TUTOR AND I'M A LITTLE
MORE RESIDENT I'M IN SUPPORT OF
SB FIVE FORTY EIGHT. THANK YOU
I'M SIXTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI MY NAME IS CHRIS COLE I'M A
CONTRA COSTA COUNTY RESIDENT
AND I'M IN FAVOR OF THE BILL.
THANK YOU I NINETY FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS KELSEY BALLESTEROS BAY
AREA RESIDENTS IN SUPPORT OF SB
FIVE FORTY THANK. THANK YOU I
HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT THANK
YOU AT THIS TIME THANK YOU ALL
GO TO THE COMMITTEE TO SEE IF
ANYONE HAS ANY. QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. SEEING THAT I'LL JUST
SAY THAT IT SOUNDS LIKE EVEN
THE OPPOSITION RECOGNIZES THAT
THIS IS A VALID PROJECT- BUT
WOULD LIKE TO SEE MONEY SPENT
SPENT ELSEWHERE AND ALL THIS
EDITORIALIZE AND SAY THAT I
WISH THAT WE- WERE PRIORITIZING
RAIL ACROSS THE STATE EVEN MORE
THAN WE- ARE CURRENTLY DOING.
EVEN THOUGH WE'RE CERTAINLY
STEPPING THAT UP SO THAT ALL OF
THESE REALLY IMPORTANT PROJECTS
THAT REDUCE GREENHOUSE GASES
AND REDUCE CONGESTION. AND
IMPROVE OUR QUALITY OF LIFE
DON'T HAVE TO FIGHT OVER EACH
OTHER. I FOR THE FUNDING I WANT
TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR BRING
FOR THIS. BILL TO REMOVE
BARRIERS TO COMPLETING THIS
VERY IMPORTANT PROJECT THAT I'M
VERY HAPPY TO SUPPORT IT TODAY.
DO WE HAVE A MOTION. WE WERE
MOTION AND A SECOND CAN WE HAVE
A ROLL CALL PLEASE. THE MOTION
IS TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS
FRIEDMAN HI FRIEDMAN HI FONG.
FONG I BERMAN BERMAN I
CUNNINGHAM CUNNINGHAM I DALY.
DAVIES DAVIES I GIPSON. KALRA
KALRA I LEE THREE I MEDINA
MEDINA I NAZARIAN. WHEN
O'DONNELL. WARD WARD I WICKS.
THE CURRENT VOTE IS NINE ZERO.
THANK YOU THE BILL IS OUT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH WILL OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS WE'RE GONNA TAKE
A QUICK MOMENT TO TAKE UP THE
CONSENT CALENDAR TO HAVE A
MOTION ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR
MOTION FOR MYSTERIOUS SECOND
FOR MR FONG CAN WE PLEASE HAVE
A ROLL CALL. I WAS ON CONSENT
FRIEDMAN. HI FRIEDMAN HI FONG.
FONG I BERMAN BERMAN I
CUNNINGHAM CUNNINGHAM I DALY.
DAVIES DAVIES I GIPSON. KALRA
KALRA I LEE. THREE HI MEDINA
MEDINA I NAZARIAN. WHEN
O'DONNELL. DONALD IS NOT AFFORD.
WARD I WICKS WICKS I HATE-
VOETEN ZERO TEN ZERO WILL HOLD
THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS- WE HAVE MISTER JONES
UP NEXT WITH S. B. TWO TWENTY
SEVEN WELCOME THANK YOU MA'AM
SURE MEMBERS AND SO I'M A
PLEASURE TO BE BACK ON THE
GREEN CARPET WITH YOU THIS
AFTERNOON. I'M GONNA BE
PRESENTING SP TWO TWO SEVEN.
FIRST OFF I WOULD LIKE TO THANK
THE CHAIR AND TRANSPORTATION
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THEIR HARD
WORK AND CRAFTING THE BILL THAT
WORKS FOR ALL PARTIES. I AM
PLEASED TO SHARE THAT I WILL BE
ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENTS
SUGGESTED BY THE COMMITTEE
OUTLINED ON PAGES FIVE AND SIX
IN THE ANALYSIS. WITH THESE
AMENDMENTS I'M GLAD TO ANNOUNCE
ALL OPPOSITION HAS BEEN
REMOVED. BUT THE COMMITTEE
MEHMET SENATE BILL TWO TWO
SEVEN WILL REQUIRE COMPETITION
OFF HIGHWAY VEHICLES TO BE
REGISTERED IN ORDER TO RIDE ON
PUBLIC LANDS. WITH OR WITHOUT
THE BILL COMPETITION OAG
WRITING IS RESTRICTED TO CLOSED
COURSES.UNDER THE FEDERAL
CLEAN AIR ACT. CURRENTLY
COMPETITION OFF HIGHWAY
VEHICLES ARE REGISTERED TO
CARBS RED STICKER PROGRAM. TWO
YEARS AGO CARP DECIDED TO IN
THIS REGISTER PROGRAM IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. AND NO OTHER AGENCY
PUT TOGETHER A PLAN TO REPLACE
THE PROGRAM. WITHOUT A NEW
PROGRAM COMPETITION ALWAYS BE
WRITERS WILL NOT BE ABLE TO GET
A DMV TITLE AND REGISTRATION.
THAT IS REQUIRED FOR A DEALER
TO FINANCE A NEW PURCHASE OR
FOR AN OWNER TO SECURE
INSURANCE. ADDITIONALLY LAW
ENFORCEMENT IS NOT ABLE TO
TRACK TRACE AND SITE ILLEGAL
AND ROGUE- H. V. WRITING IF THE
VEHICLE HAS NOT BEEN REGISTERED
THROUGH THE DMV. MY OFFICE HAS
BEEN ALMOST TWO YEARS WORKINGWITH STAKEHOLDERS INCLUDING
ONLY TO BE COMPETITION OR
ORGANIZATIONS- HV MANUFACTURES
AND SEVERAL STATE AGENCIES. SB
TWO TWO SEVEN HAD STRONG
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IN THE
SENATE. AND HAS SEVERAL
BIPARTISAN CO AUTHORS IN BOTH
HOUSES. AND I'VE GOT- MADAM
CHAIRMAN A COUPLE WITNESSES I
BELIEVE IN THE GALLERY TO SPEAK
IN FAVOR OF THE BILL. YES AND I
HAVE TO GO AND VOTE IN ARTS BUT
BEFORE I GO BECAUSE I DON'T
KNOW WHEN I'M COMING BACK
EXACTLY I WANT TO THANK YOU.
FOR TAKING THE MOMENTUM FOR
BEING SO WILLING TO WORK WITH
US- ON THIS BILL I WOULD VERY
MUCH APPRECIATE IT WITHOUT ANY
CHALLENGE OVER THE MICROPHONE.
TO MR FONG THANK YOU. WILL
PROCEED WITH A YOUR FIRST
WITNESS- MR MCHALE. MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE TERRY
MCHALE WITH ERIN READ
NECESSITATES REPRESENTING A
CONSORTIUM OF OFF HIGHWAY
VEHICLE RECREATIONISTS. IN THE
PAST I CAN'T THINK OF
LEGISLATION THAT'S MORE
CONTROVERSY OVER AN OFF HIGHWAY
VEHICLE RECREATION THIS
SITUATION LIKELY IS DIFFERENT.
THIS LEGISLATION AS A RESULT OF
COMPROMISE. AND COLLABORATION
BETWEEN THE- HBK. IN AND OTHER
STATES. IT CERTAINLY THE DEATH.
IT ALSO RECOGNIZES THE COMP
MOTORCYCLE RACING WE BRINGS ME
OF TO THIS OF. IS A STAPLE
EARLY. CONTINUES BEFORE ALSO
CONTINUES THE FISCAL STRUCTURE
OF PLACING REGISTRATION AND
COMPETITION STICKERS ON COMP ON
COMPETITION VEHICLES IN
CONTINUING THE REGULATION THE
ENFORCEMENT OF OFF HIGHWAY
VEHICLE WRECKED RECREATION AND
TAKING CARE OF ENVIRONMENTAL
NEEDS. WE WANT TO THANK SENATOR
JONES AND HIS STAFF FOR ALL THE
WORK WE HAVE DONE ON THIS AND
THE OTHER STAKEHOLDERS FOR
THEIR WILLINGNESS TO WORK WITH
US AND WE ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
ON SB TWO TWO SEVEN THANK YOU.
I THINK YOU HAVE TO GET. THE US
WILL GO TO JEAN TURNER. HELLO
MY NAME IS JEAN TURNER I'M A
FREELANCE JOURNALIST IN THE
MOTORCYCLE INDUSTRY I SPENT
NEARLY EIGHTEEN YEARS WRITING
AND WRITING OFF ROAD DIRT BIKES
ARE NOT ONLY MY LIVELIHOOD BUT
A WAY OF LIFE FOR MYSELF MY
FRIENDS AND MY FAMILY. I'M HERE
TO SPEAK TODAY TO YOU AS A
JUDGE NOT AS A JOURNALIST BUT
AS A CALIFORNIA RESIDENT AND
OFF ROAD ENTHUSIASTS. THE CARD
PLAN TO SUNSET THE RED STICKER
PROGRAM HAS LEFT A LOT OF OUR
COMMUNITY FEELING LEFT IN LIMBO
WITHOUT THE ABILITY TO REGISTER
ENTITLE ARE OFFERED MOTORCYCLES
THERE IS CONFUSION AS TO THE
FUTURE OF OUR SUPPORT. OF NOT
ONLY RECREATIONAL USE OF
COMPETITION VEHICLES BUT
AMATEUR COMPETITION MOTORCYCLE
EVENTS AND WHETHER OR NOT THE
GOVERNMENT IS CLOSING IN ON OUR
WAY OF LIFE. I TOOK IT UPON
MYSELF TO CREATE AN
INFORMATIONAL VIDEO ON THE
CURRENT RED STICKER SUNSET TO
HELP CLARIFY WHAT'S HAPPENING
AND WHAT IT ALL MEANS GOING
FORWARD NOW THAT THE TWENTY
TWENTY TWO DIRT BIKES ARE
ARRIVING. THE VIDEO HAS
RECEIVED OVER A THOUSAND VIEWS
IN FOUR DAYS AND HAS PROMPTED
DOZENS OF COMMENTS QUESTIONS
AND CONCERNS FROM OUR
COMMUNITY. I'VE BEEN CONTACTED
BY FAMILIES WHO ARE WONDERING
IF THEY SHOULD HOLD OFF ON
PURCHASING NEW DIRT BIKES I'VE
SPOKEN TO DEALERS WHO ARE
CONCERNED THAT PEOPLE ARE BEING
DISSUADED FROM BUYING NEW
BIKES. WITHOUT ANY TYPE OF
TITLE REGISTRATION AVAILABLE IT
FEELS AS THOUGH THE SIGNIFICANT
PURCHASES ARE NOT PROTECTED AND
COULD RUN INTO COMPLICATIONS
WITH THINGS LIKE FINANCE
TRANSPORTATION AND INSURANCE. I
WOULD LIKE TO ADD THAT I
UNDERSTAND THE RED STICKER
PROGRAM WAS NEVER DESIGNED TO
BE A PERMANENT SOLUTION AND
THAT THE ONLY TO BE COMPETITION
COMMUNITY. MUST DO OUR PART TO
CONTRIBUTE TO REDUCE EMISSIONS.
I GREW UP IN LOS ANGELES AND AS
A CHILD OF THE EIGHTIES BELIEVE
ME I UNDERSTAND THE PROGRESS
THERE THE AIR RESOURCES BOARD.
AND THAT IT MUST CONTINUE. BUT
I FEEL THIS CAN BE ACCOMPLISHED
WITHOUT RELEGATING THE CURRENT
OFFERED COMPETITION COMMUNITY
TO A SHADOW POPULATION. THAT
WILL NOT ONLY BE UNABLE TO
ENJOY LEGAL LAND USE BUT WILL
NO LONGER BE ACTIVELY
CONTRIBUTING TO LAND
MANAGEMENT. SUSTAINING ARE
RIDING AREAS UNDER THE NEW CAR
REGULATION. MY HOPE IS THAT THE
PASSAGE OF SB TWO TWO SEVEN
WILL NOT ONLY HELP MY INDUSTRY
AND COMMUNITY TO MOVE FORWARD.
WITH THE ABILITY TO FINANCE AND
SECURE THEIR PURCHASES. BUT
WILL HELP FACILITATE A GREATER
NET EFFECT OF WORKING TOGETHER
TO REACH NEW EMISSIONS TARGETS
WITH MINIMAL DAMAGE TO OUR
INDUSTRY. I RESPECTFULLY
ENCOURAGE YOU TO SUPPORT THIS
MEASURE. I THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
I BELIEVE THE MEHMET'S REMOVE
OPPOSITION BUT WE HAVE TO
LISTED- TWO INDIVIDUALS LISTED
AND IN OPPOSITION- AS WELL
BARRETT. ON THE PHONE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH I'M WILL BARRETT
I'M THE DIRECTOR OF CLEAN AIR
ADVOCACY FOR THE AMERICAN LUNG%
ASSOCIATION- THE LUNG
ASSOCIATION WAS OPPOSED TO THE
LEGISLATION AND PRINT THAT
WOULD OVERRIDE THE HEALTH
BENEFITS OF CLEAN AIR
REGULATIONS RELATED TO
EMISSIONS NON COMPLIANT OFF
HIGHWAY. RECREATIONAL VEHICLES
OPERATING ON PUBLIC LANDS WITH
THE AMENDMENTS BEING TAKEN
TODAY THE AMERICAN LUNG
ASSOCIATION IS HAPPY TO REPORT
THAT WE PROMOTE OUR OPPOSITION
WE THANK YOU SENATOR. THE CHAIR
AND COMMITTEE STAFF FOR YOUR
WORK ON THIS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. I THANK YOU VERY MUCH. A
DAY ABROAD. ARE YOU AVAILABLE.
YES GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
MEMBERS DANIEL BROUGHT ON
BEHALF OF THEIR CLUB CALIFORNIA.
CLEAR IN OPPOSITION TO THE DOWN
AND PRINT SITE WITH THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS THAT
STRIKE SECTION FIVE THE BELL-
WE ARE ALSO PLEASED TO REMEMBER
APPLICATION YOU WANT WE WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR HIS STAFF THE
COMMITTEE STAFF ENSURE FRIEDMAN
FOR ALL THEIR HARD WORK ON THE
BALLOT THANK YOU VERY MUCH. I
THANK YOU WILL NOW GO TO THOSE
OF THE PUBLIC WHO WANT TO SPEAK
IN FAVOR THE BILL. PLEASE
PROCEED IF SOMEONE HERE IN THE
US MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THE
COMMITTEE JAMES LOMBARDO SENIOR
ON BEHALF CALIFORNIA MOTOR
CYCLISTS ASSOCIATION OR THE
ONES TRYING TO SELL THESE
VEHICLES THAT ARRIVE IN OUR
SHOW ROOM. IN THE NEXT COUPLE
WEEKS THIS BILL WILL CLARIFY
FOR THE BUYERS THAT THEY WOULD
BE ABLE TO OPERATE THE NEXT
YEAR. WE ARE JOB PASSAGE THANK
YOU. I THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
SEEING NO ONE ELSE IN THE
CHAMBERS NO WONDER ABOUT
TESTIMONY SITE WILL NOW GO TO
THE PHONES- OPERATOR WE YOU-
SEE IF THEY'RE ANY INDIVIDUAL
PUBLIC THAT WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION TO U.
S. B. TWO TWO SEVEN. IF YOU
WISH TO MAKE A COMMENT ON SB
TWO TWO SEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE
AT TEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. I
CURRENTLY HAVE ABOUT. THIRTEEN
COMMENTS IN Q. FOUR TWO ONE
NINETY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
DON EMMERT OR AMA DISTRICT
THIRTY SIX IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU I NINETEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD-
CAMERA YARBOROUGH DISTRICT
THIRTY SEVEN IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU I WON ALL THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD- NICHOLAS HARRIS AMERICAN
MOTORCYCLIST ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU RYAN
SEVENTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD-AFTERNOON MY NAME IS CHRIS
MORTON WITH CALIFORNIA MOTORS
CORP USA AND I SUPPORT SB TWO
TWO SEVEN. THANK YOU I DON'T
WANT TO WAIT SPACE FOR OUR- HI
TAYLOR LASHED WITH MODERATE
PENINSULA POWER SPORTS WE'RE IN
FULL SUPPORT OF SB TWO TWO
SEVEN. THANK YOU RYAN TWENTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS KEVIN FELT PORT WITH
MOTION PRO AND I'M IN SUPPORT
OF SB TWO TWO SEVEN THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU RYAN
TWENTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY
NAME IS STEVE COURTS OFFER
FRESNO CALIFORNIA I AM A MEMBER
AND VOLUNTEER FOR A U. S.
FOREST SERVICE- RESOURCE
ADVISORY COUNCIL FOR FRESNO
MADERA COUNTY AND I SUPPORT S.
B. TWO TWO SEVEN. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I'M FIFTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
MEGAN MCCOY DISTRICT MANAGER
WITH CONTACTING MOTORS
CORPORATION USA AND I SUPPORT
THE FELLOW. THANK YOU RUN ONE
OR NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS DAVE ANTONSSON OWNER OF
CONTRA COSTA POWER SPORTS IN
CONCORD CALIFORNIA AND I
SUPPORT THIS BILL AND URGE YOU
TO VOTE YES. THANK YOU I'M
EIGHTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY
NAME IS CYNTHIA RATE I AM
EMPLOYED BY HONDA KAWASAKI KTM
OF MODESTO AND I SUPPORT SB TWO
TWO SEVEN THANK YOU. THANK YOU
LINE TWENTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS JEFF
ROSE WITH CAL STAR KEYS MOTORS
CORPORATION USA AND ROSEVILLE
CALIFORNIA RESIDENT AND I
SUPPORT SB TWO TWO SEVEN THANK
YOU. THANK YOU RYAN ONE OF
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS CANDY WITH TIME KEEPERS
MOTORCYCLE CLUB DOWN I SUPPORT
SB TWO TWO SEVEN THANK YOU.
THANK YOU RYAN FIFTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YEAH MY NAME
IS MIKE SUMMER I AM WITH THE
OVER THE HILL GANG VETERAN
MOTORCYCLE CLUB AND I SUPPORT
SB TWO TWO SEVEN. THANK YOU
RANGE FIFTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. IS A TEMP BUILD WITH
BETA MOTORCYCLES USA I'M IN
SUPPORT OF SENATE BILL THREE TO
SEVEN THANK YOU. THANK YOU I
HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENTS THANK
YOU AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU
OPERATOR- WILL NOW BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE FOR A FOR
MEMBERS HAVE QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. WE'LL MOTION. BY LAW
LAURIE DAVIS A SECOND. SECOND
MISTER GIBSON. ANY ANY ANY
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
C. NG C. NO QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS IN THE COMMITTEE- I
SAID I WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
CLOSING SB TWO TO SEVERAL
CREATE A MUCH NEEDED
REPLACEMENT REGISTRATION
PROGRAM FOR OUR CONSTITUENTS.
THIS BILL WILL PRESENT MANY
ENVIRONMENTAL BENEFITS THAT
COME WITH REGISTRTION
INCLUDING THE ABILITY TRACK
TRACE AND SITE ILLEGAL WRITERS
WEATHER WITHOUT THIS BILL
COMPETITION WOULD BE WRITING
WILL BE RESTRICTED TO CLOSE
COURSES ON PUBLIC LANDS SB TWO
TWO SEVEN REPRESENTS A TRUE
COMPROMISE BETWEEN
ENVIRONMENTAL CONCERNS AND OFF
HIGHWAY VEHICLE COMMITTEE THANK
YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT TODAY AND
I ASKED FOR AN AYE VOTE. I
THANK YOU SENATOR JOHNSON WE
HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND. A
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO WATER PARKS AND
WILDLIFE FRIEDMAN. FONG HI FONG
I BERMAN BERMAN I CUNNINGHAM
CUNNINGHAM I DALY. DAVIES.
DAVIES I GIPSON GIPSON I KALRA.
KALRA I THREE. YOU KNOW FOR MY
BILL THE NOT LOADING MEDINA AND
LET HIM TO DENOUNCE ACTUALLY BY
THIS AREA. WHEN I O'DONNELL
MODANO I POURED WITH THE FOURTH
WARD I WICKS. WICKS NOT VOTING.
NUMBER OKAY- THE CURRENT VOTE
IS TEN ZERO DO YOU ON THE BACK
TO MR DALY. I'M SORRY- DALY AYE
OKAY. ELEVEN ZERO. A NEGATIVE
AVAILABLE MUCH ELEVEN ZERO WILL
HOLD THE- THE ROLE OPEN FOR
MEMBERS THANK YOU SENATE
MEMBERS APPRECIATED. WE HAVE
ABSOLUTELY THE CENTER LEYVA
HERE- SB THREE SEVEN TWO. HE'S
PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR VICE
CHAIR GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS SB
THREE SEVENTY TWO ESTABLISHES
THE MEDIUM AND HEAVY DUTY ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLE I THINK A-
SENATOR JONES I THINK YOU LEFT
YOUR PHONE HERE. YES. I WILL
SAVE IT FOR YOU LET ME START
OVER THREE SEVENTY TWO
ESTABLISHES THE MEDIUM AND
HEAVY DUTY ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLE FLEET PURCHASING
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM WHICH WILL
BE ESTABLISHED IN THE
CALIFORNIA AIR RESOURCES BOARD
AND ADMINISTERED BY THE
CALIFORNIA POLLUTION CONTROL
FINANCING AUTHORITY THIS
PROGRAM WILL IN CONSULTATION
WITH STAKEHOLDERS DESIGN NEW
FINANCING TOOLS TO HELP OWNERS
OF MEDIUM AND HEAVY DUTY
VEHICLES PURCHASED CLEANER ZERO
EMISSION ALTERNATIVES AS MANY
OF YOU ARE AWARE OF MEDIUM AND
HEAVY DUTY TRUCKS AND BUSES ARE
A MAJOR SOURCE OF AIR POLLUTION
IN CALIFORNIA CONTRIBUTING TO
POOR AIR QUALITY IN NEGATIVE
RESPIRATORY HEALTH OUTCOMES.
THESE EMISSIONS HURT THE HEALTH
OF CALIFORNIANS ESPECIALLY
THOSE IN UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES AND
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED
POPULATIONS REPLACING THESE
VEHICLES WITH ZERO EMISSION
ALTERNATIVES IS NEEDED TO
REDUCE THE HARMFUL AIR
POLLUTION IT NEGATIVELY IMPACTS
PUBLIC HEALTH AND WORSENS
CLIMATE CHANGE CALIFORNIA'S
CURRENT SOLUTION FOR FINANCING
THE TRANSITION TO ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLES HAVE A VOUCHER AND
GRANT PROGRAMS IN ORDER TO MEET
THE DIVERSE FINANCIAL NEEDS OF
CURRENT AND FUTURE FLEET OWNERS
IT IS IMPORTANT THAT THE STATE
PUTS MORE TOOLS IN THE TOOLBOX.
TRANSITIONING PLEASE SHOULD BE
STRAIGHTFORWARD AND EQUITABLE
WELL FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO
LIVE IN THE AREAS WITH HIGH
CONCENTRATIONS OF DIESEL
POLLUTION EVER THE BUSINESS
OWNERS WHO MANAGE THESE
VEHICLES THE INTENT OF THIS
BILLS TO GET THE STATE TO THINK
CREATIVELY ABOUT HOW WE CAN
BEST LEVERAGE STATE FUNDS BRING
IMPACT PRIVATE CAPITAL IN
INSTANCES WHERE THAT MAKES
SENSE TO PROVIDE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE TO MAXIMIZE THE
ABILITY FOR FLEETS OF ALL SIZES
TO TRANSITION TO ZERO EMISSION
OPTIONS. SB THREE SEVENTY TWO
WILL CREATE A ONE STOP SHOP
WEBSITE TO PROVIDE INFORMATION
ABOUT ALL PERTINENT POTENTIAL
FINANCING GRANT OPTIONS AND
OTHER TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE THAT
IS AVAILABLE TO HELP OF TEAM
FINANCING FOR THOSE VEHICLES WE
KNOW THE TRANSITIONING TO ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLES IS A KEY
COMPONENT. TO ENSURING BETTER
HEALTH AND ECONOMIC BENEFITS
FOR. AS WELL AS HAVING A ROBUST
AND CREATIVE FINANCING TOOLS
THAT WILL HELP TO ACCELERATE.
OUR ABILITY TO GET CLEANER AND
GREENER TRUCKS ON THE ROAD.
WITH ME HERE ODD TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OR MICHAEL COLEMAN WITH
THE ENVIRONMENTAL DEFENSE FUND
THE BILL MCGOVERN WITH THE
COALITION FOR CLEAN AIR THEY'RE
BOTH CALLING IN MEMBERS WITH
APPROPRIATE I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. WE'VE MOTION
SECOND AT THE AT THE CENTER
LEYVA WE WILL NOW MOVE TO- TO
MICHAEL COLVIN WAS THAT WITH
THE FIRST ANIMAL IN A BILL
SECOND. YES HI GOOD AFTERNOON-
MEMBERS OF THE TRANSPORTATION
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS MICHAEL
COLEMAN WITH CONTAMINANTS AND
FUND WE ARE THE PROUD SPONSORS
THE SENATE BILL THREE SEVEN TO
CLEANER AND GREENER TRUCKS. IN
MEDIUM AND HEAVY DUTY VEHICLE
MARKET WHICH INCLUDES
EVERYTHING FROM HEAVY TRUCKS
DELIVERY VANS THE CITY BUSES
AND GARBAGE TRUCKS. IS
TRANSITIONING. TO INTERMISSION
PETER. THIS TRANSITION WILL
HAVE BEEN OUT AND ON ARTS WAS
BY PA. ESPECIALLY WHEN
CONSIDERING LOCAL AIR POLLUTION
THE THIRTY HELP IMPROVEMENTS.
CALIFORNIA CANNOT TRANSFORM
THIS MARKET IF YOU CAN PUBLIC
FUNDS IT IS TIME TO BRING IN
PRIVATE CAPITAL TO GENERATE
LEVERAGE IN ORDER TO MAKE THIS
TRANSITION AS EXPEDIENT AND
EQUITABLE A POSSIBLE. SENATE
BILL THREE SEVEN. IT SHE'S
THREE KEEPER. BURKE IT'S A
PLACE CALLED LIKE MONEY
ACCORDING NEEDED MOST BY 75% OF
THE TO ARE VULNERABLE. I TO
THANK OUR INVITE JUSTICE
PARTNERS REQUIRED WITH- THAT'S
ON THE TECHNICIAN. SECOND IT
ENABLES PRIVATE INVESTMENT AND
FINANCING OPTIONS FOR ALL FLEET
SIZES BY DIRECTING THE
CALIFORNIA POLLUTION CONTROL
FINANCING AUTHORITY TO UTILIZE
THEIR EXISTING RELATIONSHIPS
WITH PRIVATE FINANCING
INSTITUTION AND WHAT THE TALK
TRUCKING INDUSTRY. EDS HE'S
THAT FINANCING AUTHORITY AT A
CRITICAL IMPLEMENTING PARTNER.
IN THIRD IT TARGETS THE FULL
SET OF RELEVANT BARRIERS
RELEVANT TO THE FLEET
TRANSITION HAVING THE AIR
RESOURCES BOARD AT THE
ADMINISTRATING AGENCY ENABLED
HIS COORDINATION INCLUDING THE
DEVELOPMENT OF THE ONE STOP
SHOP WEBSITE. DONE RIGHT SB
THREE SEVEN TO PULL DELIVER
CRITICAL SOCIETAL AND ECONOMIC
BENEFITS INCLUDING COULD
INCREASE PUBLIC HEALTH REDUCE
CLIMATE POLLUTION LOWER
LIFECYCLE COSTS FOR THE
OPERATOR OF THE VEHICLE. I'D
LIKE TO THANK SENATOR LEYVA AND
HER SOCCER THERE CLEAR FEET
LISTEN ENTIRELY CLEAR SAID. AND
I ENCOURAGED HER AYE VOTE THANK
YOU. I THINK WE SHOULD CALL THE
WILL NOW MOVE TO BILL MCGOVERN
PLEASE PROCEED. IT GOOD
AFTERNOON COMMITTEE MEMBER BILL
MCGOVERN WITH THE COALITION FOR
CLEAN AIR IN SUPPORT OF SB
THREE SEVENTY TWO. THE MOVEMENT
OF GOODS BY TRUCK IS- ESSENTIAL
CORE KANEMI BUT ALSO A MAJOR
CONTRIBUTOR TO AIR POLLUTION IN
CALIFORNIA AND SO WE NEED TO
CLEAN UP. THE TRUCKING SECTOR
AND BURLY RAPIDLY- AND WE CAN
DO THAT WE CAN MOVE GOODS
WITHOUT INFLICTING TOXIC DIESEL
EXHAUST AND OUR COMMUNITIES. SO
THIS BILL WILL PROVIDE-IMPORTANT FINANCING TOOLS THAT
WILL COMPLEMENT SOME OF THE
REGULATORY MEASURES THAT HAVE
BEEN ADOPTED OR ON THEIR WAY TO
ADOPTION AT THE AIR RESOURCES
BOARD. AND WE THINK SOME OF THE
STRONG FEATURES OF THE BILL
INCLUDE ITS FOCUS ON
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES- PORT
TRUCKS. IN ON SMALL WEEKS. FOR
ALL THESE REASONS WE URGE YOU
TO APPROVE THE BILL. TODAY TO
THIS COMMITTEE THANK YOU. I
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I DON'T
BELIEVE WE HAVE ANY WITNESSES
LISTED IN OPPOSITION- SO WILL
NOW GO TO THE PUBLIC- SEE IS
THERE ANYONE IN THE CHAMBERS I
LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF. A
OF SB THREE SEVEN TO SEE NONE
NO ONE IN THE ROAD TEST MY SITE-
WILL GO TO THE- TO A OPPOSITION
SEEN OPPOSITION HERE IN THE
CHAMBERS AND THE MOTORS WEBSITE
WHEN I GO TO THE PHONES
OPERATOR WILL YOU- SEE IF
THERE'S ANYONE THE PUBLIC THAT
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OR IN OPPOSITION TO YOU- SB
THREE SEVENTY TWO. THANK YOU IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK ON SB THREE
SEVEN TWO PLEASE PRESS ONE AT
THE END ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE
CURRENTLY HAVE ABOUT ELEVEN IN
Q. OR TO LINE ONE OR TWO PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU KAREN G. ON
THE SECURITY ON BEHALF OF WE
TRIED IN THE CALIFORNIA
HYDROGEN COALITION IN SUPPORT
BEING HERE. THANK YOU RIGHT ONE
ALIVE AND SHE'S FOR HAD. THANK
YOU WILL PAIR UP WITH THE
AMERICAN LUNG ASSOCIATION ALSO
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU I WANT TO
FOLLOW PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON BUT ASSURED FONG AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS JONATHAN PLAY
ON BEHALF OF THE PORT OF SAN
DIEGO CALLING IN SUPPORT OF SB
THREE SEVENTY TWO. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU RYAN ONE OF FOUR
PLEASE FOR HAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
COMMITTEE MEMBERS- MY NAME IS
BEN KELLER VOLUNTEER AT THREE
FIFTY BAY AREA ACTION AND THERE
WITH ME AND SPEAKING TODAY ON
BEHALF OF. OURSELVES SAN DIEGO
THREE FIFTY THREE FIFTY SOUTH
PLANNED SO CAL THREE FIFTY
SOUTH BAY LA THREE FIFTY THREE
FIFTY VENTURA THREE FIFTY
SILICON VALLEY AND THREE FIFTY
HUMBOLDT. ON IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU RIGHT
ONE THIRTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MISTER TERRY MEMBERS BASSIL
ALSO ON BEHALF OF INLAND EMPIRE
UTILITIES AGENCY I WOULD LIKE
TO THANK THE SENATOR FOR HER
WORK WITH US ON THIS BILL AND
AMENDMENTS AND WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU I WANT FOURTEEN
PLEASE FOR AT. WITH THE
CALIFORNIA OF CONSERVATION
VOTERS IN COURT AND WAS ALSO
ASKED TO REGISTER TO A
CORPORATE ACCOUNT FOR YEAH.
THANK YOU RIGHT SIXTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. DO JACK WOULD
BE HAPPENS CAL START IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU RYAN SEVENTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
MICHAEL PIMENTEL HERE ON BEHALF
OF THE CITY AND COUNTY OF SAN
FRANCISCO IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
I'M SIXTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON ERIN RODRIGUEZ
UNION OF CONCERNED SCIENTISTS
AND SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU RIGHT ONE FIFTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO WILL BRING HER ON
BEHALF OF THREE FIFTY
SACRAMENTO IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU RIGHT EIGHTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MICROBES IN I'LL BE
HAPPY CALIFORNIA THE MYSTICAL
UTILITIES ASSOCIATION SUPPORT.
THANK YOU I HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENT THANK YOU AT THIS TIME
THANK YOU WITH THAT WE WILL
MOVE BACK TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
ANY QUESTIONS FOR THE AUTHOR
ANY COMMENTS. SEEING THAT I
WANT TO THANK YOU CENTER LABOR
FOR INTRODUCING THIS BILL TO
HELP FLEET OWNERS TRANSITION TO
ZERO EMISSION VEHICLES TO MEET
ALL OF OUR CLIMATE GOALS. VERY
MUCH APPRECIATE YOUR WORK ON ON
THIS TOPIC- WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
WHICH IS RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU WE HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECOND. WE HAVE A
ROLL CALL PLEASE. THE MOTION IS
TO PASS TO NATURAL RESOURCES
FRIEDMAN. HI FRIEDMAN HI FONG.
FONG I BERMAN. BERMAN I
CUNNINGHAM. CUNNINGHAM I DALY
DALY AYE DAVIES. GIPSON GIPSON
I KALRA. KALRA I LEE. LEE AYE
MEDINA MEDINA I NAZARIAN
NAZARIAN I WENT. WHEN I
O'DONNELL O'DONNELL I WARD.
WARD I WICKS WICKS HI FOURTEEN
ZERO THANK YOU THE BILLS OUT
WILL BE THE ROLE OPEN THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR THANK YOU MEMBERS
THANK YOU I THINK I SEE SENATOR
MEN. WELCOME SIR YOU'RE HERE
WITH SB FIVE HUNDRED YOU CAN
BEGIN WHENEVER YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU CHAIR FRIEDMAN THANK
YOU MEMBERS I WANT TO THANK THE
STAFF FOR THEIR DILIGENT WORK
ON THIS MEASURE LAST FRIDAY WE
CAME IN AGREEMENT WITH
OPPOSITION. AND ARE PREPARED TO
ACCEPT AMENDMENTS THAT
CLARIFIES THE ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLE REQUIREMENTS ON THIS
BILL ONLY APPLY TO TAUNUS
VEHICLES WITH THE MODEL YEAR
TWENTY THIRTY ONE OR LATER AND
ONLY THOSE THAT ARE UNDER EIGHT
THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED ONE
POUNDS RATHER THAN TEN THOUSAND
ONE POUNDS AS ORIGINALLY STATED
IN OUR BILL. HIS NAME IS ALSO
MAKE CLARIFYING CHANGES THE
DEFINITION OF A ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLE TO MATCH THE EXISTING
DEFINITION IN LAW AS WELL AS TO
REFLECT THE DEFINITION OF
ECONOMIST VEHICLE AS SPECIFIED
IN THE IN THE REGULATIONS. SO I
PRESENT TO YOU SB FIVE HUNDRED
WHICH REQUIRES ALL NEW LIGHT
DUTY AUTONOMOUS VEHICLES TO BE
ZERO EMISSION BY TWENTY THIRTY.
THIS IS A COMMON SENSE MEASURE
THAT WILL ALLOW OUR STATE TO
HELP REACHES AND VICIOUS YET
NECESSARY CLEANER GOALS
ESPECIALLY AS WE KNOW THE
VEHICLE EXHAUST IS NOT ONLY
TOXIC IN IN RELEASING TOXIC
POLLUTANTS BUT IS ONE OF THE
MAIN DRIVERS. OF CARBON
EMISSIONS I WILL HELP US TO
REACH GOVERNOR JERRY BROWN'S
EXECUTIVE ORDER OF ATTAINING
FIVE MILLION JOBS ON THE ROAD
BY TWENTY THIRTY. AND GOVERNOR
GAVIN NEWSOM'S. ANNOUNCEMENT TO
TRY TO COMPLETELY PHASE OUT
GASOLINE POWERED CARS BY TWENTY
THIRTY FIVE. THE TENNESSEE
ECKELS ARE OUR FUTURE AND THERE
ON THE HORIZON SOONER THAN WE
THINK- AND DUE TO TECHNOLOGICAL
CHANGES- THEY CAN CLEARLY BE
PART OF A CLEAN EQUITABLE
TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM. PROVIDED
THAT THEY ARE ZERO EMISSIONS
AND HELP TO SUPPORT A MULTI
MODAL TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM. WE
NEED SMART POLICIES TO HELP
STEER AV DEPLOYMENT. ALONG WITH
OTHER PARTS OF OUR TRANSIT
SYSTEM TOWARDS A SHARED YOUR
MISSION FUTURE. WHICH IS WHY WE
HAVE INTRODUCED THIS BILL- AV
TECHNOLOGY IS NOT SOMETHING
THAT IS SCIENCE FICTION AT THIS
POINT BUT A REALITY OF THE VERY
NEAR FUTURE- AS YOU PROBABLY
ALL KNOW WE HAVE OUR FIRST ADDS
ON THE ROAD ALREADY. AND MANY
MORE WILL BE ON THE WAY. THEY
CAN EITHER BE CONTRIBUTORS TO
MORE CARBON EMISSIONS OR THEY
CAN HELP TO STEER OUR FLEET. OF
TRANSPORTATION IN THE STATE
TOWARDS YOUR EMISSIONS. BUT WE
ALSO KNOW THAT THE HARDWARE IS
ALREADY HERE- I PURCHASED MY
OWN FIRST HYDROGEN FUEL CELL
CAR JUST A WEEK AGO. AND WE
THIS IS NOT SOMETHING THAT'S
WAY OUT THERE THE HARDWARE IS
OUTPACING THE SOFTWARE AT THIS
POINT. IS MUCH EASIER TO GET A
ZERO EMISSION VEHICLE TODAY
THAN TO GET AN AUTOMATED
VEHICLE. AND I THINK IT MAKES
COMMON SENSE IT'S GOOD
PRECEDENT TO SET BEFORE WE
DEPLOY A LOT OF ATVS ON THE
ROAD. TO REQUIRE THAT THE B.
ZERO MISSION. THIS MEASURE
SUPPORTED BY A BROAD COALITION
ENVIRONMENTAL PUBLIC HEALTH AND
LABOR GROUPS- THOMAS VEHICLES
MAY BE ABLE TO DRIVE THEMSELVES
BUT WE NEED TO STEER THEM IN
THE RIGHT DIRECTION SO- I URGE
YOU TO CONSIDER THIS VOTE AND
VOTE I'D- AND WITH ME ON THE
LINE TODAY TO TESTIFY HAVE
ELIZABETH URBAN. SENIOR
TRANSPORTATION ANALYST FOR THE
UNION OF CONCERNED SCIENTISTS
AND NADIA ANDERSON SENIOR
GOVERNMENT MANAGER FOR A
CRUISE. A LEADING. ECONOMIST
VEHICLE COMPANY. THANK YOU WITH
THE MOST A SECOND ONE NUMBER TO
THE SUPPORT WITNESSES ON THE
TELEPHONE OPERATOR IF YOU COULD
OPEN THE LINE FOR ELIZABETH
IRVINE. THANK YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON CAN YOU HEAR ME
YES. GREAT THANK YOU AGAIN FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TO THE
COMMITTEE THIS TIME IN SUPPORT
OF SB FIVE HUNDRED WHICH WOULD
REQUIRE AUTOMATED VEHICLES TO
BE DEPLOYED AS EUROVISION
VEHICLE- AS I MENTIONED
PREVIOUSLY EASIER TO SEE THE
NATION'S LEADING SCIENCE BASED
NONPROFIT PUTTING RIGOROUS
INDEPENDENT SCIENCE TO WORK TO
SOLVE OUR PLANET'S MOST
PRESSING PROBLEMS. EXPERT
CONSENSUS THAT ELECTRIFYING A
VISA IS ONE OF THE ESSENTIAL
COMPONENTS TO ENSURING THAT
THEY'RE A PART OF THE
SUSTAINABLE- PART OF OUR
TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM. FOR
EXAMPLE RECENT RESEARCH BY UC
DAVIS FOUND THAT PERSONALLY
OWNED AB IS ARE LIKELY TO
SIGNIFICANTLY INCREASE VEHICLE
MILES TRAVELED WITH A LARGE
PORTION OF THOSE MILD COMING
WINDOW PASSENGERS IN THE
VEHICLE. THEY ALSO FOUND THAT
EITHER LIKELY TO SHIFT PEOPLE
AWAY FROM LOWER EMISSION THOUGH
IT'S LIKE PUBLIC TRANSIT. UCS
RESEARCH FOUND THAT THE
POTENTIAL FOR EIGHTIES TO
INCREASE EMISSIONS AND AIR
POLLUTION EVEN IN A SCENARIO
WHERE POLICIES ENCOURAGE
PULLING IN TRANSIT. OUR
RESEARCH ALSO FOUND THAT
NEGATIVE IMPACTS SUCH AS
CONGESTION AIR POLLUTION WERE
LIKELY TO HAPPEN
DISPROPORTIONATELY IN
COMMUNITIES ALREADY
EXPERIENCING ENVIRONMENTAL
INJUSTICES. WE CAN ALSO FROM
THE RAPID DEPLOYMENT OF RIDE
HAILING WHICH UCS AND CARD HAVE
FOUND TO INCREASE EMISSIONS
COMPARED TO PERSONAL CARDS.
ACCORDING TO UCS ANALYSIS THE
AVERAGE RIDE HAILING TRIP IS
69% MORE POLLUTING THAN THE
TRAINS THEY REPLACE. THESE
REPORTS AND OTHERS HIGHLIGHT
THE NEED TO DEPLOY AB IS AS
THAT IN ORDER TO MITIGATE
EMISSIONS IMPACT. AS PART OF A
BROADER STRATEGY TO REDUCE
EMISSIONS FROM TRANSPORTATION.
THE OVERALL DIRECTION OF
CALIFORNIA POLICIES CLEAR WE
ARE MOVING TOWARD A ZERO
EMISSION TRANSPORTATION SYSTEMS
AND EMERGING TECHNOLOGIES LIKE.
AUTOMATED VEHICLES SHOULD BE
LEADING THE WAY. THIS BILL IS
CONSISTENT WITH OTHER
GOVERNMENT ACTIONS. SUCH AS THE
EXECUTIVE ORDERS THE TENDERNESS
MENTIONED- REQUIRING TRANSITION
TO JOBS AND CARS AND PASSENGER
TRUCKS- CALPERS DRAFT FRAMEWORK
WHICH WAS DEPLOYMENT OF ZERO
EMISSION AV IS AS PART OF ITS
FIRST GUIDING PRINCIPLE. THAT
CLEAN MILE STANDARD APPROVED A
MONTH AGO TODAY BY CARD THAT
REQUIRES RIDE. HAILING VEHICLES
TO TRANSITION TO THAT. I AND I
SHOULD MENTION THE TYPICALLY
MOUNTED A ALREADY THE SECOND
BUT NOT ALL EIGHTIES WHICH
POINTS THE NEED FOR. THE BILL
AS WELL. I AND JUST TO CLOSE
ONE OF MENTION THAT COME
ALREADY DEPLOYED ELECTRIC IF.
ACCORDING TO THE STATE'S
DISENGAGEMENT REPORTS ABOUT 50%
OF THE TESTING MILES IN TWENTY
TWENTY WERE EECTRIC. THE
TECHNOLOGY IS FEASIBLE
NECESSARY AND CONSISTENT WITH
EIGHT GOALS. GIVEN THESE
FACTORS. DEPLOYING A BEES
POWERED BY FOSSIL FUELS IN
CALIFORNIA WOULD BE LIKE TO
PLAYING A SMARTPHONE WITH A
ROTARY DIAL FINISH UP PLEASE.
YES THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK WITH YOU
TODAY AND RESPECTFULLY ASK YOU
TO VOTE IN FAVOR OF SB FIVE
HUNDRED. THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
NADIA ANDERSON IS NEXT.
OPERATOR. FIND IT OPEN.
FRIEDMAN AND EFFECTIVE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME TODAY MY NAME IS NOT
A ANDERSON I'M A NUMBER CREATED
GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS TEAM AND HE
TAKES A CRACK AT THE FOR SB
FIVE HUNDRED CREW THE ALL
ELECTRIC SELF DRIVING COMPANY
WITH A MISSION TO BUILD THE
WORLD'S MOST ADVANCED VEHICLE
THAT THEY CAN CONNECT TO PLACES
THANK AND EXPERIENCE TODAY CARE
ABOUT. WE HAVE FOUND IT ON THE
THAT YOU ADEQUATE TODAY FUNDS
FALSE IN CARBON POLLUTION IS
ONE THE MAIN REASONS WHY TODAY
CHECK THE IS RESPONSIBLE FOR
OVER 4% OF HOW CAN EMISSIONS
AND HOW THESE KIND OF CRISES
DIRECT AND IMPACT ON OUR
COMMUNITY WE BELIEVE THAT THE
CAR ENGINE. CONVINCINGLY
MITIGATE THESE MEGA KAT. I CREE
WE BELIEVE IN CHALLENGING THE-
QUO. OUR VEHICLE BEEN ALL OF
THAT YOU THE DAYS. IN
CALIFORNIA HAPPENED 100% BY
RENEWABLE AND- GENERATED RIGHT
HERE AND I HOME STATE
COMPLAINING. S. FIVE OFFER OUR
SUPPORT OF SB FIVE HUNDRED.
OVER PAKISTAN TO WITHDRAW
COALITION INCLUDING SEVERAL IN
A INTEREST. ENVIRONMENTALISTS
LABOR AND PUBLIC HEALTH GROUP.
ARE YOU TO SUPPORT THE THAT.
YOU FOR BUT WAY TO CALIFORNIA
TEACHER ECONOMICALLY ANYBODY.
AND THEN AGAIN THE CLEAR. AND
MISSION. IN AND PUSH NEEDED TO
SUPPORT CARD. THAT ARE STATE
APART. AN EXISTING UP IN A
POSITION OF THE SHINING. OF THE
ENERGY TRYING. AND TRANSIT
SUPPLY IN THE COMING. AT THE
STATE WE NEED TO TAKE EVERY
STEP OF RIGHT NOW. TO REDUCE
OUR MISSION. STARTING WHEN THE
MAIN. THE TRANSPORTATION. SB
FIVE HUNDRED CAL HAVE OFFERED.
TAKE ANOTHER STEP TOWARD ME I
AM BASICALLY NICKEL AND THAT
THE THING OF HOW WE BUILD BE
ABLE TO. FOR TO. IN OPPOSITION
CAMERYN DIMITRI AN AERIAL WOLF
OPERATOR IF YOU CAN PLEASE.
FIND THEM ON THE PHONE LINES.
CUEBALL FINDER OPEN. PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THE MANAGER CAN YOU HEAR
ME YES WE CAN WELCOME. THANK
YOU BUT VENTURE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS ARIELLE
WALL MY SERVICE GENERAL COUNSEL
TO THE SELF DRIVING COALITION
FOR SAFER STREETS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR GIVING ME THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY TODAY
AND SB FIVE HUNDRED. BUT WE
BACKGROUND SELF DRIVING
COALITION IS COMPRISED OF
FIFTEEN OF THE WORLD'S LEADING
AUTONOMOUS VEHICLE TECHNOLOGY
COMPANIES ACROSS. THE
TECHNOLOGY RIDE SCHERING
TRUCKING AND AUTOMOTIVE SECTORS
PERMITTED TO OUR MISSION IS TO
BRING THE BENEFITS OF FULLY
SELF DRIVING VEHICLES TO
CONSUMERS AND SUPPORT THE SAFE
AND SWIFT DEPLOYMENT THE
TECHNOLOGY. WITH RESPECT SB
FIVE HUNDRED WE HAVE BEEN
CONCERNED THAT THE BILL COULD
DELAY THE ROLLOUT OF AB. IN THE
STATE AND THEN I CALIFORNIA
BENEFITS OFFERED BY AUTONOMOUS
VEHICLE TECHNOLOGY WHICH COULD
INCLUDE PREVENTING THOUSANDS OF
ROADWAY FATALITIES HOWEVER. AS
SENATOR MAY NOTED WE UNDERSTAND
THERE HAS BEEN AGREEMENT ON
AMENDMENTS THAT IF ADOPTED
WOULD ACT TO MITIGATE THESE
CONCERNS AS A RESULT THE SELF
DRIVING COALITION IS PREPARED
TO REMOVE OUR OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL SHOULD THESE AMENDMENTS BE
ADOPTED IN THE FORM THAT WE
HAVE SEEN. WE GREATLY
APPRECIATE THE WILLINGNESS OF
SENATOR MAN IN THE COMMITTEE TO
WORK WITH AB DEVELOPERS ON A
COMPROMISE WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING TO ENSURE EIGHTIES
CONTRIBUTE THE CALIFORNIA'S
ENVIRONMENTAL GOALS. IN A
MANNER THAT CONTINUES TO ALLOW
FOR THE SAFE AND SWIFT
DEPLOYMENT OF ALL A. B. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR TIME AND
CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU DO WE
HAVE. CAMERON TO MEET HER. ON
THE LINE. OR ANYONE FROM
TECHNICALLY DO. WE DO CARE GOOD
AFTERNOON SURE MEMBERS MY NAME
IS KIM IMAGE AND EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF. WITH THE NATIONAL
BIPARTISAN NETWORK OF
TECHNOLOGY CEOS AND SENIOR
EXECUTIVES THAT PROMOTES THE
GROWTH OF THE INNOVATION
ECONOMY. WE REPRESENT OVER
EIGHTY COMPANIES IN FOUR
MILLION EMPLOYEES. TECH HAD
PREVIOUSLY HAD AND BECAUSE OF A
SIMILAR POSITION BUT DUE TO.
THE ONGOING CONVERSATIONS IN
AGREEMENT WITH YONKERS OFFICE
WE ARE PLANNING TO MOVE INTO A
NEUTRAL POSITION. WE APPRECIATE
ALL THE WORK OF THE COMMITTEE
CHAIR THE DILIGENT COMMITTEE
STAFF AND THE AUTHOR'S OFFICE
TO INCORPORATED ARE SUGGESTED
AMENDMENTS. AMONG OTHER CHANGES
DAMAGE WOULD HAVE THE- THE BILL
APPLIES STARTING JANUARY FIRST
TWENTY THIRTY TO EIGHTY IS
BETTER MODE YEAR TWENTY THIRTY
MINUTES LATER WITH A GROSS.
VEHICLE WEIGHT RATING UNDER
EIGHT THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED AND
ONE TOWNS. THAT ARE OPERATED
PURSUANT TO A DEPLOYMENT PERMIT
WITH THOSE CHANGES AS OUTLINED
IN THE PROPOSED AMENDMENTS.
TECH THAT WILL MOVE TO NEUTRAL
POSITION THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME AND CONSIDERATION. WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU IN
THE OFFICE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. CAN WE PLEASE IS THERE
ANYONE IN THE ROOM WELL WISHING
TO SPEAK FOR OR AGAINST THE
BILL. C. NINE LET'S OPEN THE
PHONE LINES FOR ADDITIONAL
TESTIMONY. FOR OR AGAINST IT SB.
FIVE HUNDRED. OPERATOR CAN YOU
PLEASE OPEN THE PHONE LINES FOR
ANY OTHER TESTIMONY FOR OR
AGAINST THE BILL. THANK YOU IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK OUT SB FIVE
HUNDRED PLEASE PRESS ONE NINE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. I CURRENTLY
HAVE ABOUT SEVEN IN Q. FOUR TWO
ONE ONE FOURTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NORTH AMERILA THE
CALIFORNIA LEGAL CONSERVATION
VOTERS IN SUPPORT AND ALSO WITH
AFTER MUCH YOUR SUPPORT IF YOUR
CALL CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU I
WON ELEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. I
WILL BE RIGHT WITH THE AMERICAN
LUNG ASSOCIATION ALSO IN
SUPPORT OF SB FIVE HUNDRED
THANK YOU. THANK YOU LINE SIXTY
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON DILLON JACK ON BEHALF
OF CAL STAR AND THE ELECTRIC
VEHICLE CHARGING ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT OF SB FIVE HUNDRED.
THANK YOU BRING ONE SIXTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. JOHN MOFFETT
ON BEHALF OF THE ALLIANCE FOR
AUTOMOTIVE IN THE NATION IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU I NINETY
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS ME AS THE RECORD FROM
THE CALTRAIN TO EUROPE COMMERCE
WE ARE NOT OPPOSED UNLESS
AMENDED POSITION BILLION
ACCORDING TO ANYTHING
OPPOSITIONAL MALL. DESCRIBED
THANK YOU I'M AT SEVEN PLEASE
GO OUT. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
PETER LAREAU WHEN YOURS FROM
THE SILICON VALLEY LEADERSHIP
GROUP AND WE HAVE A MOST UNLESS
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED POSITION
ON THE BILL FOR THE REASONS
OUTLINED IN OUR LETTER AND
THOSE AMENDMENTS WERE OUTLINED
EARLIER TODAY BY THE AUTHOR.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU I HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENTS THANK YOU AT
THIS TIME. THANK YOU WITHOUT
WILL GO TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. VICE
CHAIR FONG. I THANK YOU VERY
MUCH CHAIR- A FEW QUESTIONS TO
THE SENATOR- I APPRECIATE. YOUR
WORK- WITH THE AUTONOMOUS
VEHICLE INDUSTRY. ESPECIALLY IN
CRAFTING THESE AMENDMENTS I DO
WANT TO ASK DO YOU TO QUESTIONS
THAT. ARE OUR BROAD BUT THERE
THE BASIC QUESTIONS I GUESS
THAT SAID OF THE FUNDAMENTAL
ISSUE AT HAND WHICH IS YOU AND
I WOULD BOTH AGREE- THAT THE
THAT THE AV SPACE IS STILL
RAPIDLY EVOLVING AND DYNAMIC
AND I AM A FAN OF THE CERTAINLY
THE PSYCHOLOGY. AND WANTED TO
GROW AND MATURE. SO CAN I JUST
ASK. WHY PLACE A MANDATE. ON
SUCH A NEW INDUSTRY RIGHT NOW
WHEN IT HASN'T FULLY. BEEN
INTEGRATED INTO SOCIETY. AND
SECONDLY HI ARE ARE THERE ANY
CONCERNS THAT. TAKE THAT AS A
STATE CALIFORNIA MAYBE PLACING
OURSELVES. AT A COMPETITIVE
DISADVANTAGE- AS MEMBERS OTHER
STATES OUR NEIGHBORING STATES-
ARE TRYING TO ATTRACT. A THOMAS
VEHICLE INNOVATORS TO THEIR TO
THEIR STATES AND WITH THEIR
LOCATIONS. THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION VICE CHAIR I
APPRECIATE THEM- ON THE FIRST
QUESTION I GUESS THIS GETS YOUR
THEORY OF WHAT ANY REGULATIONS
MEANT TO DO I THINK FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE IS THE AUTHOR. THIS
REGULATIONS MEANT TO HELP STEER
THE DEPLOYMENT OF AV'S IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION SO THAT THEY
THIS IS AN AREA WHERE WE DON'T
WANT REMAIN AGNOSTIC ON THE
TYPES OF TECHNOLOGIES THAT ARE
USED TO POWER THESE CARS. WE
REALLY DO WANT AN EASIER
MISSION SO WE WANT THAT PROCESS
TO START NOW THIS BILL GIVES
THEM PLENTY OF FOREWARNING AS
THEIR TESTING AND I SHOULD NOTE
THAT THERE IS NO PROHIBITION ON
TESTING AB TECHNOLOGY ON GAS
POWERED CARS. IT'S JUST THAT
WHEN THEY DEPLOY- THEY ARE
REQUIRED TO BE ZERO EMISSIONS
BY TWENTY THIRTY OR LATER AND I
THINK THAT IS A WORTHWHILE GOAL
BECAUSE AS WAS MENTIONED THERE
IS SIGNIFICANT CONCERN THAT
ABC. WILL ACTUALLY ADD
SIGNIFICANT NUMBERS OF
PASSENGER VEHICLE MILES
TRAVELED BUT ON TOP OF THAT WE
ARE TRYING TO GET TO ZERO
EMISSIONS THESE ARE NOT CARS
THAT ARE MEANT TO BE CHEAP DATE
THAT YOU AVOID A LOT OF THE
EQUITY CONCERNS- THAT HAVE.
GUIDED SOME OF OUR DECISIONS
WITH YOUR- IT MANDATES IN OTHER
AREAS- THESE ARE GOING TO BE
HIGH PRICE WHETHER THEY'RE FOR-
YOU KNOW WITH- THOSE WERE
TRYING TO BE FIRST EARLY
ADOPTERS OR- THE RIDE SHARING
MEANT TO BE CHEAP AND SO I
DON'T SEE ANY GOOD REASONS WHY
THEY SHOULD NOT BE ALL YOUR
MISSIONS BY TWENTY THIRTY
THAT'S THE TREND ALREADY WE'RE
JUST GIVING IT A LITTLE PUSH.
IN THE BACK HERE TO TRY TO MAKE
SURE THAT THERE ARE NO OUT
LIARS- FOR ALL THE REASONS THAT
WE'RE TRYING TO REDUCE CARBON
EMISSIONS RIGHT NOW WE'RE
SEEING. RIGHT NOW HOW URGENT IT
IS I THINK TO GET TO ZERO
EMISSIONS AS QUICKLY AS
POSSIBLE I THINK THIS IS A
PROMISING TECHNOLOGY. AND AS
FAR AS YOUR SECOND QUESTION YOU
KNOW I ACTUALLY DUG DEEP ON
THIS BECAUSE I DIDN'T WANT TO
BE SOMEBODY THAT WAS STANDING
IN THE WAY OF THE TECHNOLOGY OR
INNOVATION- BUT I COULD NOT
HEAR A SINGLE ACTUAL. CREDIBLE
EXAMPLE OF HOW THIS WAS
DISRUPTING ANY KIND OF- PLANS
BECAUSE MOST THESE COMPANIES
ARE EITHER ON HYBRIDS OR ZERO
EMISSIONS ALREADY. AND. IT'S
NOT A HUGE STRETCH TO. MOVE TWO
ZERO. THE TECHNOLOGY ALREADY
THERE. AND CERTAINLY I WOULD
HOPE THAT THE TECHNOLOGY FOR
ZERO EMISSIONS VEHICLES. IN THE
NEXT EIGHT YEARS WILL CONTINUE
TO PROCEED- ADAM AT THE PACE
HAS BEEN PROCEEDING AT OR MORE
RAPIDLY. IN WHICH CASE I DON'T
THINK THIS WILL BE AT ALL A
STRETCH FOR THOMAS VEHICLES TO
DEPLOY THEIR SOFTWARE
ESSENTIALLY. ONTO THEIR
MISSIONS PLATFORM. SO I DON'T
KNOW IF THAT IS RESPONSIVE YOUR
QUESTION VICE CHAIR. NO
ABSOLUTELY I THINK I THINK THAT
I THINK THAT- I CERTAINLY
APPRECIATE THAT SENTIMENT I
THINK- I THINK. YOU AND I MAY
HAVE A DIFFERENT PERSPECTIVE IN
TERMS OF JUST. ALLOWING
EMERGING TECHNOLOGY TO- TO
PROCEED OR TO BE TWO TO. FOUR
TO KIND OF. THRIVE AND PROSPER
IN A YOU AND I DON'T KNOW I
THINK WE KNOW WHAT'S GOING TO
HAPPEN IN THE NEXT. TWO TO FIVE
YEARS WE'RE GONNA SEE A LOT OF
ADVANCEMENTS IN THIS SPACE.
THAT WE MAY NOT BE ABLE TO
PROJECT ARE NOW. AND FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE IT'S ALWAYS ONE OF
THOSE- THOSE THOSE DICEY YEAH
DECISIONS TO BE ABLE TO PLACE A
MANDATE. OR PLACE ANY. AS
RIGIDITY INTO SOMETHING THAT WE
DON'T KNOW. WHAT IT'S GOING TO
WHAT'S GOING TO BE ALLOWED BUT-
IT'S ONLY APPRECIATE YOUR WORK
I CAN'T SUPPORT THE BILL THIS
TIME BUT- AND SO THEY WANT TO
CONTINUE WORKING WITH YOU ON
THIS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ANY
OTHER MEMBERS. WELL I WILL JUST
ADD TO THAT I WANT TO FIRST
THANK THE SENATOR FOR WORKING
ON THIS BILL FOR TAKING ON THIS
VERY HEAVY VERY LARGE TOPIC AND
TO MOVING INTO PUSHING THIS
INDUSTRY AND IS A VERY
IMPORTANT DIRECTION- TO MAKE
SURE THAT- IT REALLY IS THE
TYPE OF- OF VEHICLES ON THE
ROAD THAT WE ALL WANT AND I
WILL JUST TAKE A LITTLE ISSUE
WITH WHAT MY VERY- THE STEAM TO
VICE CHAIR SAID. THE EMERGING
TECHNOLOGY HERE IS THE SOFTWARE
AND SENSORS IT IS NOT THE
ENGINE- THE ENGINE SHOULD BE AS
ADVANCED AS EVERYTHING ELSE
THAT'S GOING ON THESE VEHICLES
AND THAT IS AB TECHNOLOGY AND
THAT IS ALREADY HERE AND
ALREADY BEING DEPLOYED SO THAT
REALLY ISN'T A STRETCH- BUT
UNLIKE A TYPICAL CAR WHICH YOU
KNOW IF IT'S BOUGHT FOR
PERSONAL USE IT MAKES IT IN THE
GARAGE A LOT OF TIME THESE
VEHICLES ARE NOT GOING TO BE
THAT THEY'RE GONNA BE PURCHASED
TO BE WERE COURSE VEHICLES ARE
EXTREMELY EXPENSIVE. AND
THEY'RE GOING TO BE RIDE SHARE
VEHICLES THAT ARE GONNA BE ON
THE STREET ALL THE TIME BUT
THEY'RE GOING TO BE TRUCKS THAT
ARE GOING TO BE ON THE STREET
ALL THE TIME AND WHEN THOSE
BUYERS MAKE THE INVESTMENT IN
THESE VEHICLES THEY'RE GOING TO
SQUEEZE EVERY YEAR AND EVERY
MILE OUT OF THE VEHICLES THEY
CAN'T THEY WILL FAR EXCEED. THE
MILEAGE AND THE USE OF A
TYPICAL PASSENGER VEHICLE AND
THAT'S WHY IT'S EVEN MORE
IMPORTANT THAT THE BEVS BECAUSE
THEY'RE GOING TO BE ON OUR
STREETS TWENTY FOUR HOURS A DAY
THEY DON'T REST PLUGIN HUMAN
DRIVER THEY COULD EASILY BE
DRIVING TWENTY FOUR HOURS A DAY
SO THEY MUST BE EV'S BECAUSE
THEY'RE GOING TO HAVE A MUCH
LARGER ENVIRONMENTAL FOOTPRINT
THAN ANY OTHER TYPE OF VEHICLE.
SO I THINK THIS IS VERY VERY
IMPORTANT I WILL SAY THE ONE
MOMENT THAT YOU'RE TAKING THAT
I WAS SORRY TO SEE YOU TAKE WAS
THE LOWERING OF THE- THE WEIGHT
LIMIT- TO CAPTURE LESS OF THOSE
LARGE HEAVY VEHICLES BUT I
THINK THAT'S CERTAINLY A
COMPROMISE THAT WE CAN ALL LIVE
WITH AND THAT'S SOMETHING THAT
WE COULD REVISIT THIS INDUSTRY
IS NOT SHOWING THAT THEY'RE
MOVING IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION
AND MAKING THOSE LARGER
VEHICLES B. BV'S WE CAN ALWAYS
COME BACK. TO THAT. NEXT YEAR
THE AFTER THE AFTER THAT SO BE
CERTAINLY WATCHING THAT TO SEE
WHAT THE INDUSTRY DOES. BUT I'M
HAPPY TO SEE EV'S. I'M SORRY
BEING DEPLOYED AND I'M VERY
GRATEFUL FOR YOU TO TAKING THIS
ON AND I ALSO WANT TO THANK.
THE OPPOSITION THAT'S NOW MOVED
TO A NEUTRAL POSITION. WE
APPRECIATE THEM STRETCHING FOR
THIS AS WELL. I DO WE HAVE A
MOTION- BUT WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE. I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
MAKING THE CASE MORE ELOQUENTLY
THAN I DID WE DIDN'T WANT TO
TAKE THE AMENDMENT BUT-
COMPROMISE REQUIRES HARD
SACRIFICES SOMETIMES. THE ONE
THING I WOULD JUST- NOTE THIS
IS NOT. A THIS IS TECHNOLOGY
AGNOSTIC SO IT DOESN'T HAVE TO
BE EV'S IT ALSO CAN BE OTHER
FORMS OF ZERO EMISSIONS
VEHICLES. BOTH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE
SORRY AND YOU'RE RIGHT I WAS
USING THAT TERM INCORRECTLY
WE'VE TRIED HERE I SHOULD NOT
BE DOING. BUT CERTAINLY THE
PRESENTS WE ALL MAKE THAT STEP-
I DO WE HAVE A MOTION. AND WE
HAD A SECOND OKAY THANK YOU
WITH THAT LET'S TAKE RECALL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO COMMUNICATIONS AND
CONVEYANCE FRIEDMAN. HI
FRIEDMAN I PHONE. ANOTHER PHONE
NO. BERMAN BERMAN I CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM NO DALY. DALY AYE
DAVIES DAVIES NO GIPSON. GET
GIPSON I KALRA. KALRA I LEE LEE
I MEDINA MEDINA I NAZARIAN
NAZARIAN I WENT. WHEN NO
O'DONNELL. O'DONNELL I WARD.
WARD I WICKS. WICKS HI. TEN
ELEVEN. ELEVEN FOUR ELEVEN FOR
THE BILLS OUT WILL BE THE ROLE
OPEN FRIDAY SEPTEMBER THANK YOU
AND NOW FOR A LAW SCHOOL TODAY
SB THIRTY THREE THIRTY NINE
WELCOME SENATOR WINNER YOU MAY
BEGIN. WHENEVER YOU'RE READY.
WE HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND.
GRADER THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ABOUT INSURANCE I DO COMMITTEE
FOR WORKING WITH US IN THIS
BILL. SB THREE THIRTY NINE-
WILL EXTEND- THE ROAD CHARGED
TECHNICAL ADVISORY COMMITTEE
FROM TWENTY TWENTY THREE TO
TWENTY TWENTY SEVEN- THIS
COMMITTEE HAS- WITH- CALIFORNIA
TRANSPORTATION COMMISSION- HAS
BEEN- PILOTING AND EVENTUAL
TRANSITION FROM DOUBTS TAX- TO
A ROAD CHARGE- IT IS. A
TERRIFIC FOR CALIFORNIA IS
MAKING ADVANCES ON REDUCING-
THE- OR INCREASING THE
EFFICIENCY OF OUR VEHICLE FLEET
AND EVENTUALLY. WE ARE MOVING
TO ALL ZERO- EMISSION VEHICLES
IN CALIFORNIA. BUT OF COURSE WE
STILL HAVE TO MAINTAIN. OUR
TRANSPORTATION INFRASTRUCTURE.
WHICH IS CURRENTLY- PAID FOR BY
GAS TAX AND SO WE HAVE TO PLAN
FOR A TRANSITION WHERE WE-
HOPEFULLY ARE NOT USING GAS- IN
THE FUTURE- AND THIS OP PILOT
PROGRAM WILL HELP US TO
FORMULATE- THAT PROGRAM- THIS
OUR LATEST VERSION WILL
AUTHORIZE. THE PRODUCTS
EXPANDS. IT'S A PURELY
VOLUNTARY PROGRAM NO ONE IS
REQUIRED TO PARTICIPATE IN A-
TWITTER EXPAND THAT SO THE
PEOPLE ARE ACTUALLY PAYING. I
GOT ALL VOLUNTARY SO THAT THEY
CAN PILOT THAT ASPECT OF THE
PROGRAM AS WELL- WE WORKED WITH
A- BROAD ARRAY OF STAKEHOLDERS.
THIS BILL JOINT. A LABOR BUYER
MENTAL BUSINESS. CONTRA SUPPORT-
AND- HAS NO RIGHT UP. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE DO
HAVE ONE WITNESS REGISTERED IN
SUPPORT. PAUL GONZALEZ SKI-
OPERATOR IF YOU CAN PLEASE
FIND. THE GENTLEMAN ON THE
PHONE. YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR FRIEDMAN
AND ASSEMBLY MEMBERS WITH THAT
POSSIBILITY SKI DEPUTY DIRECTOR
FOR LEGISLATION AND FINANCE AT
THE CALIFORNIA TRANSPORTATION
COMMISSION. THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE CONTACT EIGHT
THREE THIRTY NINE TODAY. THIS
LEGISLATION ADDRESSES THE
CRITICAL ISSUE WHICH IS THE
FIFTEEN ABILITY OF FUNDING TO
SUPPORT CALIFORNIA'S
TRANSPORTATION INFRASTRUCTURE.
THE GAS TAX WHICH HAS LONG
SERVED AS THE FOUNDATION FOR
EVERYTHING THE REVENUE NEEDED
TO PAY FOR OUR STATE MULTIMODAL
TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM IS
EXPECTED TO BE A LOT AND MUCH
REVENUE AGAIN CALLED BECOME
MORE FUEL EFFICIENT AND DRIVER
SHIFT TO ZERO EMISSION VEHICLE.
AT THE HURT CALIFORNIA'S
WORKING TO PREPARE FOR THIS
REVENUE IMPACT SINCE TWENTY
FOURTEEN WHEN THE LEGISLATURE
CREATED THE BURKE CHARGE
TECHNICAL ADVISORY COMMITTEE.
TO EXPLORE A NEW FINANCING
SYSTEM WHERE DRIVERS WOULD PAY
BY THE MILE RATHER THAN BY THE
GALLON. SB THREE THIRTY NINE
WOULD ALLOW THE DATE COULD
BUILD UPON PREVIOUS EFFORTS BY
AUTHORIZING A NEW PILOT
PROGRAMS TAX REVENUE COLLECTION.
THIS WOULD ENSURE THE STATE
HAVE THE RIGHT PROPERTY IN
PLACE FOR MINISTERING BURKE
CHARGE PAYMENT WHEN THE TIME
COMES FOR ACTUAL IMPLEMENTATION.
THIS IS IMPORTANT BECAUSE THE
TRANSITION FROM A GAS TAX
SERVER CHARGE WILL BE A MAJOR
CHANGE FOR CALIFORNIA DRIVERS
AND THE STATE NEEDS TO BE
PREPARED TO MAKE SURE THE
TRANSITION GOES. MEDINA
POSSIBLE. SB THREE THIRTY NINE
ALLOWED STATE TO WORK THROUGH
THESE ADMINISTRATIVE ISSUES BY
TESTING REVENUE COLLECTION ON
VOLUNTEER PROJECTS AND FOR
STATE OWNED VEHICLE. THE
CALIFORNIA TRANSPORTATION
COMMISSION SUPPORTS THIS
IMPORTANT EXCEPT FOR ENSURING
THE FIFTEEN ABILITY OF OUR
TRANSPORTATION FUNDING. AND
THANK SENATOR WIENER
INTRODUCING THIS LEGISLATION
WHICH WOULD IMPLEMENT ONE OF
THE COMMISSION RECOMMENDATIONS
TO THE LEGISLATURE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE HAVE NO
OPPOSITION REGISTERED IS THERE
ANYONE IN THE ROOM WISHING TO
GIVE ANY ADDITIONAL TESTIMONY
FOR AGAINST THE BILL. SEEING
NONE WILL MOVE TO THE PHONES TO
SEE IF THERE'S ANY ADDITIONAL
TESTIMONY FOR OR AGAINST. THE
SB THREE THIRTY NINE. THANK YOU
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK OUT OF
THREE THREE THREE NINE PLEASE
PRESS ONE AT THE END ZERO AT
THIS TIME. ABOUT CUBA FORTY ONE
SEVENTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MICHAEL PIMENTEL
EXPECTED DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA TRANSIT ASSOCIATION
VOICING OUR SUPPORT FOR THIS
BILL- DRIVE UP. THANK YOU RYAN
ONE OF SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU- MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MORE TALK ON BEHALF OF
THE ORANGE COUNTY
TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU I'M SEVENTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS MATT
KREMIN T. ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA NEVADA CONFERENCE OF
OPERATING ENGINEERS HERE TODAY
IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I NINETY THREE SCORE
AT. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR ABOUT
ROBINSON WITH CELLULAR INTO
SMALL ALONG ON BEHALF THE
CEMETERY OF CITY COUNTY OR
STATE USUALLY GOVERNMENT HI
MATTEO CALTRAIN ELECTRIFICATION
CALTRAIN ALL SUPPORT. THANK YOU
I NINETY TWO PLEASE GO OUT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE OF THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU VERY
SIXTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS AARON RODRIGUEZ THE
UNION OF CONCERNED SCIENTISTS
AND SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU RUN ONE TWENTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THE NEW MANAGER MEMBERS
MY NAME IS MARC WATTS ON BEHALF
OF TRANSPORTATION CALIFORNIA WE
SUPPORT THIS MEASURE NURTURE-
I'VE OF THANK YOU. THANK YOU
RYAN WON TWENTY ONE SEATS FOR
HAD. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR TODD
BALLOON SIGN FOR THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA CONTRACTORS
ASSOCIATION- IN SUPPORT S. B.
THREE THREE NINE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I'M SEVENTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE SEVEN
FIVE YEAH JIM CHANG WITH THE
ARTICLES ON THE CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. THANK YOU
I HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT THANK
YOU AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU
WITHOUT WILL GO BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE TO SEE IF ANYBODY HAS
ANY COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS.
SEEING NONE I APPRECIATE YOU
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD OF
COURSE OURSELVES WHICH WE ALL
LOVE AND COURAGE DUMPY GAS TAX.
BUT PUT A LOT OF WEAR AND TEAR
ON THE ROADS AS WELL AND THIS
WILL HELP US FIGURE OUT HOW TO
CHARGE THEM FOR THAT- WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE. RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL. OKAY WE HAVE A MOTION
AND A SECOND I BELIEVE CORRECT.
YES OKAY CAN WE HAVE A ROLL
CALL PLEASE. THE MOTION IS TO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS FRIEDMAN
I FRIEDMAN HI FONG. FONG NO
BERMAN. BERMAN I CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM NO DALY. DALY AYE
DAVIES DAVIES NO GIPSON GIPSON
I KALRA. KALRA I LEE LEE I
MEDINA MEDINA I NAZARIAN.
NAZARIAN I WENT. WHEN NO
O'DONNELL- DONAL I WARD. WARD I
WICKS. HI FOUR WEEKS HI CURRENT
VOTE IS TWELVE FOR DIFFERENT
YEAH THE WE WILL POST THE BILL
IS OUT LET'S GO AHEAD AND START
CALLING THE- PREVIOUS BILLS FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS OF ANY IF THERE
ARE ANY ABSENT MEMBERS WHO ARE
WITHIN YOUR SHOP PLEASE COME SO
THAT YOU CAN VOTE. I RESIGNED.
DALY DALY I GIPSON GIPSON AYE
NAZARIAN. THIS AREA I WENT. I
DON'T ON CONSENT CONSENT. WHEN
I O'DONNELL. DONALD HI FILE
ITEM ONE. KURD VOTE NINE ZERO
CUNNINGHAM. CUNNINGHAM I LET'S
SEE HERE IN THIS AREA. NAZARIAN
I WENT. WHEN I WARD WARD I
WICKS WICKS HI FINAL WILL. TEN
THIRTEEN THIRTEEN ZERO THIRTEEN
ZERO LEVEL WITHOUT IF YOU CAN
READ THE BILL NUMBER AS WELL AS
THE ITEM NUMBER- I'M SORRY THE
FOLLOWING SB SIXTY SIX I
APOLOGIZE FILE ITEM FIVE SP.
FIVE FORTY EIGHT CURRENT VOTE
NINE ZERO DALY. DALY HI GIPSON
GIPSON I ZERO ZERO IN I- A WIN.
FISHING WITH ADDRESSES HERE
OKAY O'DONNELL. O'DONNELL I
WICKS WICKS I. YOU CALL WHEN
YOU GET WHEN. FOR FIVE FORTY
EIGHT. HI WHEN I. YOU KNOW FOR
FIVE FORTY OVER THE BILL NUMBER
WRONG. FILE IN FIVE SB FIVE
FORTY EIGHT. YES OKAY. GIPSON
TODAY GIPSON FOR FIVE THIRTY
OKAY. THREE FOUR FIVE SIX SO
FIFTEEN ZERO THE FINAL VOTE
FILE ITEM SEVEN. S. V. TWO
TWENTY SEVEN FRIEDMAN FRIEDMAN
I NAZARIAN. I. THIRTEEN ZERO
FINAL VOTE. FILE ITEM EIGHT SB
THREE SEVENTY TWO CURRENT VOTE
FOURTEEN ZERO DAVIES. I'M SORRY
SAY THAT AGAIN. THE FILE ITEM
EIGHT SB THREE SEVENTY TWO. HI
OKAY. FIND OF A. FIFTEEN ZERO.
JOHN FILE ITEM THIRTEEN CURRENT
VOTE. TWELVE FOR. GOING TO THE
RIGHT TO THE. THREE THIRTY NINE
THAT WOULD START WITH A LOT A
SOME SORRY FIREABLE ELEVEN FOR.
BECAUSE IT IS AFTER THAT AND WE
ARE DONE. WE'RE GOOD. HEY WE
GOT EVERYBODY YEAH OKAY THANK
YOU SO MUCH WE'RE ADJOURNED.